i'm guessing is just like uh
it's it is the the winner will
they just divide the 250 by amount of
points right robert
please do correct me from wrong okay i'm
trying to do the math here it's a little
too early for math so don't worry we're
going to cover the chest
we don't have to turn the mathematicians
but yes if the rest the second 250
will be split by win percentage so if
someone's eighty percent of their games
they're uh getting quite a payday
i like to hear that i like to hear that
it's definitely very very exciting i
mean
do you have any um predictions for today
we're asking the heart any questions
first i don't know what to expect
honestly because
sagar doesn't play as much chess not
nearly as much as eric but saga is a
very talented player
he's way better known these days for his
commentary
and for his journalism and he's an
exceptional human being
i have so much respect for both of these
players and i
would love to give you a prediction so
i'm going to go with eric rosen just
based on the experience level in online
chess
that definitely does sound right eric is
also a streamer i mean
sagar does as well but i have seen eric
play a lot of games recently and
um you know whoever wins today will get
to play
the one and only levy rosman also known
as gotham chess
um in the round of eight so today's
match is going to be
extremely extremely exciting i'm hyped
i'm hyped too because we get so much
blitz chess and
players are going to be stressed out we
get to just casually talk about their
games 75 minutes of five minute plus one
second
blitz 45 of the three plus one the final
25 minutes of bullet chest
nemo i've seen you be playing a lot of
bullet on stream lately so i'm guessing
you're excited for that
oh for sure i mean i'm really excited to
just commentate
too on one minute bullet just it's uh
it's one of the rarer experiences i
think as a
commentator because you don't really get
to see that so
i'm definitely very excited i mean the
five plus one blitz is also going to be
very intense i
i'm going to make the wild assumption
that the five plus one blitz is going to
be
the time format with the most um let's
say
let's say you know most
solid games let's put it that way
because as we all know as the time gets
lower and lower
as we go into one minute bullet chess
it's
games tend to you know pieces tend to
fly across the board
so this will be very exciting although
you'd be surprised by
how many time scrambles you get in the
five minute portion where people are
you know up plus 10 and then all of a
sudden they lose on time so
anything can happen in these formats i
love commentating this nemo i'm so
excited to commentate today with you
i can't wait for the games to lift up
that's what i'm always waiting for it
will remind everybody of the prize fund
here we were talking about that
at the top we're not gonna be
mathematicians they could figure out
their prize funds
but really what they want to do is
qualify for the quarterfinals
and keep moving on for sure i mean this
is very very exciting we've
chess.com has put up a really really big
price pool and um you know
we're having a lot of fun here so
i am super excited to see the games and
i personally much like you know what
robert said i think
i do think that eric might be the slight
favorite here
just in terms of online uh chess playing
experience
so the games i'm sure are going to be
extremely exciting
extremely extremely and we all know how
much eric
loves his opening traps um i've been
caught in a few of those myself
you know so i do think we'll see some
very exciting games
yeah and if we do not see a stafford
gambit today that's the ultimate do as i
say not as i do actually
that's like yeah that's really would be
disappointing to many of the fans who
will be tuning in waiting for a stafford
gambit since that's been popularized by
eric rosen
yeah for sure i mean eric has made a lot
of openings very popular
um through his amazing youtube and
twitch channels so
a lot of you guys might actually be
getting um
some inspiration from today's games at
least i definitely hope some of you guys
will get inspiration from
today's games oh of course i mean sagar
op right that's
that's what we're it's all about right
now we got i am rosen who's
been one of the most instructive chess
personalities for many years now
sagar who uh you know maybe newer to the
scene for some people
but i like i said i have such tremendous
respect from
he's been a journalist for a long time
he's like a great source of
information and reporting and he's also
an amazing chess player people sometimes
forget about that
when you play less and end up talking or
writing more
but sagar is an amazing amazing asset to
the chess community
for sure i mean i've known sagar uh
personally for a few years now as well
he's he's definitely being at i think
every single
you know world chess olympiad i've been
to and i'm sure robert is familiar as
well since you've been a coach at a lot
of those events
so sagar is an um absolute amazing
personality for sure
i'm so curious though the first game
we'll be telling because
yesterday we had tanya sanchez who
doesn't play so much online
blitz chess she was quite slow in the
early stages of the five minute and she
was saying that
you know you get into this sense of
comfort that you have five minutes
rather than three minutes that's so much
extra time and then you kind of
needlessly spend
time in the opening so i'm very curious
to see how much preparation these two
players have done and for sagar in
particular
will he be up to the task of keeping up
on the clock
with eric rosen yeah i mean i do also
want to say that preparing as eric rosen
is a bit scary you know
because uh he's got a lot of openings
he's got a lot of
things that will pop out at you and you
have to like prepare a lot of things
a lot of lines a lot of variations and
i'm just you know
for a blitz game that's a lot of stuff
to remember right so this
will be a very very tense match oh
absolutely and these kind of gambits
even if they may not work in a classical
game
you surprise one in your opponent they
spend half their time just trying to
figure out the first 10 moves in the
game
that can work to your benefit it also
also can backfire let's be clear
some of these gambits have risks they
are gambits you typically give a pawn or
some sort of material
so i'm very curious to see which eric
rosen we get maybe we'll get a calm
air he is a very calm person overall but
i wouldn't be surprised if in the first
few games
just to dip his toes in the water if he
just challenges sagar in
sort of standard opening fair i
definitely do want to see what eric has
prepared for today i mean we're
definitely expecting to see
some of his normal um and by normal i
mean the not so normal openings just to
make it clear
whenever we think normal we're usually
thinking stereotypical spanish italians
but with eric you never really know
um so by normal of course i mean eric's
normal openings which
could be really anything and of course
we'll see how sagar
um does respond i'm not quite familiar
with sagar's um
gameplay to be honest but i do
think that he is pretty meticulous so um
i'm sure he's prepared something and i
want to see that well i think what
you're saying makes complete sense
you've studied a lot of chess and uh you
know you don't really
are not really familiar with him and
that makes sense because he doesn't play
so much anymore
and that goes to show that it's been a
while
since sagar has dusted off those pieces
and played some of these serious matches
but he is
really talented uh he's uh he's like
some sharp play he's a d4 player by
trade if i'm not mistaken
so that's going to be an interesting
clash of styles
yeah well this will be exciting i mean
he he's uh looking a little bit nervous
there
i mean i think eric is still still
getting fully set up so
this will be very very intense and i
think one of the things that i'm going
to be looking for today and this
uh especially in the longer games is
really like internal gameplay style too
because
eric is quite tactical he likes to
sacrifice
i had quite a few queens um chucked at
me when i was playing a match against
him myself
so that was definitely very exciting um
but
but you know this is this is the kind of
game play that
excites me you know the kind of
sacrifices the
the attacks the aggression um so there's
going to be a lot of very very fun stuff
i'm looking at the chat already going
wild let us know who you're rooting for
come on we want to know who you are
rooting for i'm guessing there will be a
lot of soccer fans in the chat
but eric rosen he's got his faithful as
well so i'm curious to see what the
breakdown's like
i already see they oh no my queen means
coming through
okay okay oh they're hyped look at that
yes let's go chad this is the kind of
energy we want to see
yes oh my gosh you know it's funny
because people
accuse me of ignoring chat i'm always
keeping an eye on you what do you think
i'm looking this way for i'm always
looking
at the chat but i see everybody there is
it feels pretty rose and heavy right now
but
i'm sure on youtube the soccer fans will
be
loud and proud for sure for sure um
there are a lot of sagar fans here as
well and i'm really happy to see that
it's a lot of we got a good match
up coming and everybody seems to be
getting very pumped and i like this
yeah this is going to be a great battle
of two of the best personalities in
chess
two of the nicest people and they don't
have to be nice i hope they realize that
today it's not about being gentlemanly
they can go and destroy each other over
the board
that's what i'm looking forward to
because when you turn these
you know pretty soft-spoken humble
people into
just competitive chess players they hold
nothing back
that's the kind of atmosphere i like
if people you know always have this
impression of chess players you know
like whatever they are in person is kind
of while they're on the board but i have
to admit when i played eric rosen his
personality reflected nothing off his
chest
and i was shocked i was so shocked i was
like
because for me i mean personally i'm i'm
quite outspoken
in person in real life and on the board
i'm like very similar but then there's
eric who uh you know is very very polite
very kind very nice and then all of a
sudden on the board i'm just getting
destroyed and i'm like
oh so that happened yep you know
so this is going to be very interesting
for sure and we do have liftoff i
am seeing game one is underway sagar's
rating
is lower than i would have expected 2224
that's a sign of somebody who is not
playing
a lot of blitz which means the increment
will be helpful and look we have
already d3 on the second move against
the car con
eric playing a quiet setup and sagar
taking over the
center here with d5 and e5
yep this is um all right at least the
opening for this one is starting out
fairly slow
whoa okay d forcing he goes d3
and then d4 what is in his bag of tricks
okay never mind
i said that and ignore what i said
ignore what i said
and forget that he's breaking the
opening principles he went d3 then went
d4
he put his knight in front of his bishop
he goes bishop d3 this move makes sense
to me he's protecting the pawn e4
he wants to take with the knight on e4
but open the board stayed up
black's king is in the center so white's
castling here i think black's just
continued the development knight to e7
makes sense with bishop g4
all right sagar is ready for a fight
okay i'm liking this he goes bishop g4
straight away i this is this is this has
become very aggressive i mean the ponds
already on d4
castle uh black needs to probably castle
really soon or he'll run into a bit of
trouble with his own king
so yeah expect 97 castle because knight
f6 everybody would be a blunder
e5 what happened and then you put a
piece in the e file when the bishop
takes the pawn
that king is in the center that's not
good so instead
we got 97 perfect response and now
castling
is going to happen but look at eric just
continuing as if
he's not down upon even material in his
mind but i think his point is after pawn
takes d5 he will win back this pawn on
d4
and black will be left with an isolated
queen pawn honestly i think i think
eric is thinking right now ah just a
pawn
you know that's not enough gotta give a
little bit more and
i'm now looking to see if eric talks to
himself while he plays because he's so
used to streaming and
just calmly telling everybody oh well
i've blown it upon you know i've seen
so many of his streams and his clips
where he's just
you know even when he's blundering he's
the nicest guy in the world like he's
the person you don't want to beat in
chess
because chess players at least at the
you know this high level they often they
enjoy their opponent's suffering eric is
just too kind you know he's like
oh well here my opponent no they they
blundered their queen and i'm gonna
checkmate them oh okay
one of my favorite like you know
interactions with eric was
one time when i made a really good move
and he was like your brain is so
big and me having never really
interacted with somebody
quite so wholesome because
my community is is a little bit you know
we're we're not we're not necessarily
the most wholesome i was just like in
shock i was like is he
is he you know being sarcastic or is he
being completely honest
and then everybody of course explained
to me that eric is very very wholesome
and he genuinely meant that so
i will until my deathbed i will remember
my brain is very big as my favorite ever
compliment
that's awesome well you know both of
these players still
they have you know nothing too tense has
happen at the moment there's been two
pawns
uh traded off here bishop b8 well i
think we know what's planned here is bit
queen to d6
let's go for an eventual checkmate on
this uh dark square diagonal here
but that doesn't look realistic right
nemo there's a knight on f3 a knight on
d4 you'd have to
take both of these knights down and i
think that eric's gonna see this coming
and on top of it i'm sure g3 is also a
fairly solid move
uh in response to queen d6 so i'm not
quite sure what soccer's plan is going
to be in this position i think i
definitely prefer white just because
black
i'm sorry about that is that you
have your attention please you have you
have my attention
that scared me honestly i thought you
were about to be
taken by a ufo yeah i uh
wow oh well you know it's amazing
i know from experience you have my
attention
sir you have all of our attention
everyone
on twitch on youtube facebook i don't
know where you're watching this
but you have our attention and this game
also has our attention
but that is one of those things that
happens you can't control that no need
to be embarrassed
i'm so sorry about that everybody i am
i guess apparently my apartment just
loves to
wake people up and like at 10 a.m
with a fire alarm well
i just want to make sure is everything
okay yeah everything's fine it's just a
test
okay good because you never know when
it's the real deal and i want to make
sure that you're prepared
and yeah for sure i mean if there was
actual fire don't worry i will i will
go out of the building oh
well look at that that was that was
funny well
here we see that cyrus queen has went
from d6 to f6
putting some pressure on this knight and
f3 but right now it's very compact
for eric all his minor pieces working
together very well
but it goes from you know you need to be
active and he goes knight h2 because the
position was solid but you need to
actually create threats and he wants to
trade bishops
and in his up with his knight on g4 so
what do you think about this nemo
um i i do like white's position i think
a lot more i think
like these these isolated pawn
structures where black
does not get an attack in um are just
end up being very uncomfortable end
games right as we know
um isolated pawns structures you kind of
don't want to exchange the minor pieces
because if you go into an end game well
the major pieces the rook
and queens are really going to just
double up on the d-pawn
and there's always the breakthrough with
the c pawn so
um it's it's the long run it's the end
game that i'm worried about for
sagar in this position and i mean i mean
that aside i think
i think knight to g4 looks very very
good here because
we've got knight takes f5 and then
possibly queen takes d5 right after so
that might
just be a free pawn or or even you know
some bishop takes h6 ideas because
we've got a potential we've got a fire
drill that's what we have
we do have a fire drill i hope this
one's not real i
at this point at this point if there's
an actual fire i'm just gonna ignore it
so like
please it sounds like it sounds like a
truck is backing up
onto stream right now that's what
oh my gosh well this knight g4 move
was important because if the knight were
on h2 this pawn h3 would be hanging so
the knight g4 inclusion
was smart by eric he does win the d5
pawn
but sometimes actually black's position
gets easier to play even though you're
down a pawn you don't have to worry
about that anymore you've lost the pawn
so you play a move like queen to g6 and
maybe at some point there will be a
sacrifice on g3 and this king
will not be that safe so i think that
cyborg's life is made
easier despite the fact that he's down
material yeah
i actually do think that instead of
queen takes d5 he did miss the very good
opportunity of playing bishop takes h6
which would have been a move that i
would have maybe
expected eric to see but it's also one
of those
you know it's it's like the first game
of the match right i don't know if he's
done tactics for 30 minutes beforehand
um the chances are he has not so puzzle
rush is not going to kick in
in the first game of the match but i'm
definitely um
excited to see some tactics coming up i
do like this queen g6 move um
i do think he's aware that you know and
games being down upon are one of the
most uncomfortable things you could
possibly get into
yeah and look at eric he's like i don't
even want to
calculate bishop takes g3 but look at
sarah he's picking up momentum in the
position h5 and
kicking the knight back his queen can
move to f5 later in the game to keep an
eye out on this
h3 pawn so i feel like white could be a
little bit stuck
and if i'm eric i need to find a
concrete plan at this moment
hmm yeah i mean is the beast upon a free
pawn
i i don't know if i'm so brave to take
that pawn but eric says yeah
me neither i i'm up one pawn i don't
need to be greedy and take a second but
yeah that you could have captured that
pawn i i just see pot
i take pawn you know that that's that's
my mental
i mean it makes it makes sense you
should always be aware when pieces are
hanging and i think that actually
wow knight to d3 i was thinking knight
c6 to save the pawn and put pressure on
this bishop here and said knight into d3
he's just trying to complicate the
position maybe there will be a sack on
f2
a sack on g3 all this kind of stuff that
eric needs to keep his eyes on it for
you know what i really like here what
queen xb7
yes it just looks so cool because rick
takes e2 doesn't work since you could
take out okay well rick's ea is probably
the much
more solid uh choice here instead of
playing queen takes piece oh he takes it
though
he sees he eats but i'm looking at h4
this king is a bit
lonely over here and if you get h4 and
attacking the pawn on g3 and if i have
to make his move g4
this bishop is very happy on the
diagonal i want the f4 square for my
knight
going forward so h4 feels like the right
play
and look at the clock by the way eric is
a minute sagar down near 30 seconds
so he needs to move and he needs to play
with the initiative i would play h4
right now
h4 is a quite an easy move to make in
these kinds of positions just because
there's
really a lack of any other other thing
oh wait that was a very fast g4
from eric and i'm not sure if i like
that move is bishop takes h2
um you could do either move right you
could take on h2o queen d6 played to go
from mate but this knight is coming to
f4 and that's just
what bothers me because if this knight's
here it's gonna sit here and h3 is a
problem
yeah i mean here i think i think white
has to play knight f1
yeah right knight of one is played with
13 seconds is uh there's only a one
second increment
as a reminder to everybody so it's it's
almost 5-0 right almost five oh just
ensuring they do not flag
right and 92 check that means the bishop
can't move because the queen was
defending the rook now the queen isn't
so i'm just trying to figure out what
white's moves are going to be i see that
i'm not getting checkmated sure
but knight f4 checked back what if i
just keep going like 92 knight f4 or
rookie 2 actually
that could be strong cutting the queen's
protection of the rook i'm going for
this attack
and only five seconds you gotta move
come on queen g6 yep clock
yep clock indeed and now queen g6 it
feels a little bit too slow
maybe this knight can come into e3 there
it goes this thing come to f5 and
it's eric who's making progress we've
solidified the position
as white and now it's going to be quite
rough
yeah the knight comes in and now bishop
e3 look at that that's a pin that you
can't get out of
just take a free knight oh no all right
well
and sagar is lost on time unfortunately
he
had a very very slim chance in that game
um on that one move exactly for one move
he had a chance
but that just goes to show you know how
strong that
uh both of these players are really i
mean eric played a very very
good game and was completely you know
trying to
demolish black so uh very well played
game by both of them however we're going
to round two
and what is this opening
well we have a you know sort of catelyn
style position with the bishop and the
long diagonal and
that's why black pushes through to d4
saying you're not getting it knight to
c3 you're not getting your pawn to d4
so this is somewhat standard fare but i
would be worried
about eric's position in the long term
you take and after pawn takes you the
semi-open file
you can try to open this bishop up on
the long diagonal i like white in these
positions
really i actually really enjoy playing
black in these positions i like going 97
and then e5
and then i always thought that black
actually has a very good control of the
center but of course i mean
it can be very easily undermined right
because
white basically has the entire queen
side we see the
a3 b4 c5 pawn push uh
b5 bomb push so yes we do see 97 here
from eric
um probably expecting an e5 coming up
very soon
yeah and i you know you the way white
can play is knight a3 maybe knight c2 to
go after this pawn you know
okay he goes knight to d2 still good but
if e5 i go rookie one
so black does get this big center so i
think it's just a stylistic choice
whereas i feel like even though my
opponent has the center i'm just trying
to
hunt it down move after move and you're
like well i have my big center
and i'm going to proudly use that to my
advantage
for sure um i mean this is
this is gonna lead to a very exciting
position i predict that
yeah i i completely agree and i think
that eric's moves through like queen d6
pawn a5 knight c5 use those dark squares
and
eventually this bishop which is stuck
that once that bishop gets to scroll
like f5 then white
can see yourself being in trouble
um i mean here i just try to
see what sagar is going to play i'm not
sure how familiar he is with these
positions but
he is letting his time run a little bit
low
yeah in both of these matches and and
that's cool like it's got me a little
bit more worried
yeah it could move like a3 that's a move
he could have played in
five seconds but he's spending more time
than
is needed to make a move like that and
there's so many ideas here for white one
idea is playing like knight h4
open this bishop up on the long diagonal
and then maybe if you allow me to get my
knight to f5 but i also have
f4 ideas once my knight's out the way
your queen is on the same line as my
rook
so knight h4 is a pretty standard idea
helping this bishop
become more powerful but he's trying to
be perfect right now that's what i think
is going on
he's not accustomed to playing chess so
much these days at least not online so
you start questioning yourself you try
to be a perfectionist and then you spend
too much time
so you don't save it for later when the
moments are more complicated
for sure um i mean here after 94 i would
my first instinct would be to play f5
but
i don't know if that's a little bit too
aggressive for this moment but
i i do think that f5 is one of those
thematic moves in this position you know
and black actually saves a move because
he doesn't have to play f6 first i mean
there's no threat on the e5 pawn he has
two knights defending
that e5 pawn so yeah no f5 is one of
those moves that you enjoy
in the meantime and then like 15 moves
later like can i play that pawn back to
f6 because my e5 pawn is so weak but
it's in the spirit of the position for
sure nemo to play f5 and i would not be
surprised if eric does that or if he
plays me like pawn a4
you often play a move like this just to
close down the queen side so both
options
look very good to me i've always had the
time to
be like yo can i push my pawns up can i
just
store my paws off the board i'll do that
but i do like to see eric play a little
bit
more solid today i think i think
he he is warming up to his usual style i
do like f6
also very positional on a4 like robert
said
also just stopping uh before ideas
but the thing is c5 happens so quickly
here and this
could be a really big problem for eric
going forward
this d6 square is this knights for the
taking there are some times where you
play b4 anyway so that your queen
if ambassador happens can get to this
diagonal uh knight h4 ideas still exist
knight f to d2 i just know these
positions very well from the white side
and
even if black is okay here i just think
it's so much easier to play for white
and
it's again stylistic choice more than
anything but i i think eric you can tell
by his time manager right now he doesn't
feel
at home in this position i i do think
that he regrets not playing i was
okay he he played f5 okay as i was
saying that i was gonna say i do think
he regrets not playing f5 earlier
because now i was gonna say the d6
square looks very strong for white
tonight i mean
sagar puts it there with barely a
moment's hesitation
and um the knight's gonna be comfy
because how do you kick it out really
i'm i'm like looking at the boar i'm
trying to figure out ways you can't move
the c6 knight away because
uh white can take on d4 i mean i was
looking maybe thinking maybe rick a5 or
take c5 just get it out but
even still it's um it's going to be very
oh
yeah he so he he says i don't want to
hear any longer because the queen does
defend but this is still good for white
you just take on c5
and it's the problem with the e5 pawn
persists so it takes
uh sorry takes takes and queens d2 for
example this e5 pawn remains a problem
i can play queen c4 check my bishop on
g2 is very powerful so even if
this pawn is captured it's going to be a
long-term problem but he takes the
bishop oh i don't like that
i don't like that decision oh wait
wait now this night on okay so we've
actually just reversed everything
now black's knight on c5 is going to be
very strong not that it's on an
outpost or anything right now but
there's just realistically nothing to
contest that night and the knight is you
know
attacking both d3 and
you're also potentially threatening to
play e4 in the near future after you
move your queen maybe to f6
oh well b6 first and then queen d6 or
queen f6 so
we do i do like this position a lot for
black i think i think eric
is going to be feeling a lot more
comfortable here
yeah it's like now you're clearly a pawn
down before
if you took back on c5 you had a direct
threat against this centralized pawn e5
but now that pawn looks safer
i don't see a clear path forward for
sagar and you can tell because he's
spending time he's like oh wait i took
on c8 and
now where do i go from here and i get
the decision you take a bishop
and so you have at least the bishop for
the cost of the pawn
but what black center it's too massive
it's too well defended
so this is going to be a tough rest of
the game for
sagar yeah for sure i mean i think
sagar is is feeling it he's down a whole
minute compared to eric right now and
i'm struggling to find a plan here for
white i'm not gonna lie what are you
thinking here
yeah plans not finding those maybe like
a rook c2 rook e2 go after the e5 pawn
but black can just play a rook to e8 you
know this rook to f8 to e8 or something
and keep it defended
uh this knight can always be useful and
depending upon and as you said e4
is on the docket so even if you get this
rook to e2 i'll play e4 with my queen on
d6 or something like that and
i'm just pushing forward so i i don't
know what to do and that's why sagar is
spending so much time
he's feeling the pressure of being down
upon down
one game in the match and when am i
going to get my victories
yeah for sure i okay queesy too i think
it's these kind of positions that are
most difficult to play in blitz where
you don't really have
tempo when you don't really have a clear
plan right because
if it wasn't over the board game it's a
bit of a different story because then
you can sit there for like 20 minutes
and be like
ah yes let me go here here here reroute
my pieces and then decide on something
but when it's blitz you kind of
you're kind of looking for plants that
are like two three moves you know and
and there's just nothing like that in
this position for white
and i mean queen c2 is obviously hitting
the c59 i'm sure
i'm sure black can just play b6 here
yeah and b6 you might have to do well
you don't have to but you would drop the
a4 pawn otherwise
but i can understand why you wouldn't
want to play b6 the knight feels a
little bit looser on c6
and white would not be opposed to taking
that once the knight moves other way
from f3
because then the e5 pawn is weaker so i
would even consider knight d2
and knight c4 getting ready to take this
to take this
and black's position looks a bit flimsy
honestly
yeah maybe maybe so i actually think
maybe now white has ideas to play maybe
knight d2 knight c4
uh hitting the oh
c4 okay so king has to go to h8 and then
mcqueen b5 is the idea going after the
pawn with the queen and the knight
is a bit stuck because the e5 pawn
behind it but i'm with you this looks
like you're kind of going
off to the side needlessly and me to
remember this knight and c5
is attacking this pawn on d3 so if the
queen never takes on d6
you drop this pawn on d3 with a fork so
queen d6 played
to just emphasize that you cannot take
on b6 without dropping material
so yeah this is um
looking i first for like actually i mean
in terms of
just the pure position right you
wouldn't think that white
is doing that badly i mean it's
you know uh
just down a pawn okay wait is the the
queen snapchat this queen no
yeah i was like okay and there's no
knight takes d3 because of queen takes
d6 as well maybe the queen would have
been better than i was six in hindsight
but
you know hindsight's always 20 20. it's
not never too late you can play queen fc
or queen h6 that's a nice move hitting
the knight now this pawn d3 is under
attack so bishop f1 i think
by default is the move time hang the
piece
hanging a piece hangs the piece oh
and sucker will
yeah you know he had that the position
he
he couldn't have asked for a better one
when he went pawn to c5 knight d6
he just didn't follow up precisely and
that's the nature of chess where even if
the engine says oh you're better
if you don't find accurate move after
accurate move it could result in
a good position for your opponent and
well what is this opening bishop see
from queenie2
wait what
huh like what's why would you put your
queen here that seems completely
unnecessary after e5
now he's thinking so this seems like
okay
that's why i'm going to play some kind
of delayed king's gambit
the king's gambit deferred i don't know
this doesn't look right from my point of
view just knight c6 bishop g4
all this stuff okay i have actually
never seen a king's gambit play this way
not that i play into a lot of king's
gambits
but this is something interesting i'm
not sure if this is home preparation or
i think it's fine for white objectively
speaking the position is okay but
there's no
benefit of having your queen on e2 it
does defend the pawn on e4 but a knight
c3
would have done the same and now you
have to watch out for knight to d4 just
exploding this pin here maybe he wants
to go queen f2
queen g3 maybe but it feels like
i don't know it just feels like a long
story here but
i'll trust eric i'll just say eric okay
man i don't understand your openings
your gambits
but it works you know it works if it
works it works and that then we'll leave
it at that
yeah and castle so both sides are
castling but now you see the benefit of
having these pawns here
where they're more advanced and so you
are the one who can
use your pawns as an attack maybe an f5
h3
g4 we all know how those positions go
where white just storms the pawns
and the black king gets in trouble
yeah this is going to be one of the more
um
oh well i mean after bishop takes f4
it's not
all too unsimilar from you know
typical italian and
spanish positions i want to say um
but every single move i'm watching is
like
i have never seen something like this
before my brain is just trying to
connect the dots
you know i'm just trying to associate
this with something i've seen before and
it's just not happening
yeah because the pawn on the attack the
italian and the spanish is an f2 but it
does look similar and this d5 idea
that is one that you see in that opening
and i think that sagar timed it
well and wait can he just give eric an
isolated pawn
we saw eric do that to sagar in the
first game
i think that now yes take on here bishop
c5 check is possible
i feel like black's pieces are coming to
life i do like this position for black i
am always very insecure about when my
opponent has a bishop no it's wait
that's
a wait oh no no no
no you can't move your rook from f8 when
you're
you can't do that this is one of the
very very typical
um spanish ideas actually with the
bishop takes f7
yeah this is thematic this is very
thematic and
oh and and eric sees that oh no
and black was having such a good
position but now after king takes f7 we
have queen c4
um and not only can white
immediately take back on c5 but the king
is actually really weak and i think
i think key f8 is
very likely oh there might already be
checkmate yeah i feel like there's a
knight g5 because
there's a mate here the sack on h7 this
i think the king has to go to g6
i i don't recommend this very often but
king g6 might be the move but you might
get checkmated there too your kids
coming to h5 like
what i don't think you survived that
either
oh this is this is gonna be very rough
kg6 knight knight h4
um king fa knight g5 yeah bishop v6
all right here it comes here comes
knight g5 here goes the checkmate
ideas from eric eric's gonna snap on
this we already know that the rook on f1
is so happy knight g5 you have to defend
against check me here you play queen to
e7 let's say
then i can oh my gosh oh he he
he didn't look at that look at that
checkmate that's what
i'm looking for it would have been very
beautiful except eric just took
the bishop oh well now the king's safe
hey
this actually isn't so bad you're down
you're down one pawn but there's an
isolated pawn on e4
this queen can soon go into the d3
square this isn't that bad
all things considered this is a pleasure
it could have been a lot worse it could
have been a lot worse i'm a little bit
surprised that eric let
sagar um get off so easily you know
knowing him he would have been like ah
yes
i can check my opponent let's do it i
mean i've seen him you know
uh oh and now
okay so i get it i get it like he's
trying to set up the
smothered checkmate here but maybe just
move like
you know queen d7 and you can block the
check with bishop e6
this these end games won't be that bad
for black but i see the eval bar is
really low so i'm guessing there's like
some kind of weird bishop e2 move
to take away the check is what should be
played but
it looks strange believe bishop v2 i
mean bishop e2 is a very unnatural move
i don't think sagar will realistically
play it so
there's also queen d3 though which is
probably the more logical
kind of move because it serves the
purpose of bishop b2 you're stopping the
opponent's queen from going to c4 and
you're also attacking you know the rook
on f1 and you're attacking the pawn on
e4 and you're connecting your rooks wow
what a great move
however it's you know putting your queen
of so high on the board is very
unnatural it's not something people
usually look for so yeah i like queen e7
and the only reason i see him with
bishop is i'm getting used to this i
never like to use engines and be honest
about it but then i see why is it so
good for black the normal moves that i'm
looking at
they're not don't look that good so then
it must be some ridiculous move that
nobody's gonna play so that's how
it's a process of elimination at this
point but here you have to play bishop
e6
uh you do not put your king in the corn
yes what were you saying about putting
the king in the corner robert would you
be as kind as to finish your sentence
for the 30
000 people we have watching here um yeah
i don't think you should put your king
in the corner because some kind of
knight f7 check looks scary but i think
what
saga is relying on is this is one check
and once the king comes here
if the knight moves out the way the
bishop will be able to return and block
the queen and attack it but
i see the eval bar skyrocket which means
yeah so it's like there must be
something that means e5 looks very
strong as well just like trying to kick
this knight out
i want to get my knight to f7 this
bishop isn't exactly well defended
either
oh that's it that's it so by playing e5
okay let me just show this your knight
moves away somewhere let's say that here
once i check you i have knight h6 double
check and your bishop falls
because that's a double check and the
bishop's no longer defended there
yes this is um looking most
uncomfortable
for black i mean honestly every single
move in this position just looks
very uncomfortable for black sigh of
relief
sigh of relief knight d2 played you can
now h6 the king has the h7 square to run
to cyrus position is all right
and he's well ahead of the clock by the
way
i i i do think that e5 still works here
i mean or you can just play knight oh
wait eric is playing
very very um timidly timidly yes
yeah it does feel that way can i even
take this pawn now and regain my
material because if you pin me
i say ah it's not that big of a pin i'll
take your knight which attacks
i i think he can i i'm not sure i mean
maybe maybe eric hasn't had his
you know his empowered tea yet
but he is playing very very timid and
that shocks me a little bit
because i'm like i mean this is not that
bad for black at all you know you might
be down a pawn but rook comes onto the
second fight and then you bring the
other wreck
over and all of a sudden black has a lot
of counter play in this position
i was going to ask do you think that
because he's up two games to none that's
why he's not taking so much risk he just
feels like hey i'm leading this match if
everything continues this way
i can just con you know keep that lead i
don't have to risk anything
but i think that's a risk in and of
itself when you stop playing
as aggressively because you're trying to
protect your lead that could go wrong as
well i think people think solid play
means safe play but that's not always
the case i i definitely
agree with you i think actually in blitz
it's always better to be on the
aggressive side of things
and um the reason for this is quite
simple right like if you're the one
attacking your opponent has to be one
defending it's always so much more
uncomfortable to be the one defending
and if you just constantly put pressure
on your opponent they're gonna start to
like lose a little bit of hope
so um i definitely would say that
eric should be playing aggressive
and that's not to even say that eric is
not aggressive he's a very aggressive
player and
um him playing so solid is really quite
against like his normal gameplay style
so that's probably the more interesting
aspect to me because if he just played
like he would
normally potentially um he might be
finding these moves but he's definitely
holding
back a little bit yeah he's going to
regret not when the king was on f8 not
playing knight g5 that is definitely an
er
rosen type of vicious mating a check
attack excuse me but right now he still
has an extra pawn opposite-colored
bishops
and saga takes on f3 he's going to trade
and you say
i'm down a pawn but my rook is way
better than your rook in the corner so
if you take
the pawn will take back we just see that
happen that's powerful rook
keeping your king stuck it on the first
rank keeping your rook tied to the a
pawn
so i think black is certainly fine here
we'll see though if black can even play
for more somehow
yeah i think this is one of those
positions where
it should be a draw but seeing how both
players
are running quite low on time you know
pieces might start flying
uh however f4 is very solid choice i
mean get you get your bishop out
oh this knight needs to get right here
if that knight gets to f3
black is just cruising in this game but
obviously that's very difficult
every single square going to f3 might be
you know defended but we can hope
oh well now that pawn is winning i think
that's what i said
95 wait a second wait a second it's
happening
it's happening now now 95 knight f3 is
actually happening
that's that checkmating configuration
you know once this knight gets to f3
you just want to take this pawn in h2
with your rook and the king is caught so
king g6 knight f3 these are moves that
cyrus you know just just go just go and
what does
what do you do here because i'm going to
go knight f3 i'm going to go h5 i'm
going to go h4 and i'm just going to
keep your king locked in the corner oh
getting checkmated oh he just doesn't he
just ignores
it here it goes here it goes here it
comes the pawn
and oh my god you played g3 to cut the
bishop off so if you can get this to
work
h4 ah that was great move rook f1 though
really good move rook f1
i can show that after the game but there
was like a really sick mating net
okay but this is winning for black
completely winning for black this king
is caught
friendly reminder to everybody that just
because it's the end game does not wait
wait wait that that the pawn oh he
dropped the pod
and that's such an important pawn and
this bishop is now protecting me
the rook take the rock it's hanging
oh my gosh what a turn of events there
i laughed my brain hasn't even finished
processing the fact that the pawn
dropped and the rook was already dropped
and i'm like
yeah i'm laughing out of like
nervousness for both players more than
anything i'm just like what's happening
but now black is up a rook so sagar is
going to get his first victory
and after the game i'll show you that
checkmate that we didn't see but
that eric prevented so oh easy 14 points
for sagar
all right let's put the analysis board
here so you'll see the live position but
right around where was it around here
before rook f1 if you played some kind
of move like rook to b1
h4 bishop c7 and g3 it cuts off the
bishop
so if pawn takes pawn rook h2 that's the
exact check mini pattern
that we were looking for is the knight
takes away the square and the rook would
land in with checkmate so
that's what we uh we're looking at
yeah i mean it's an end game
but as a reminder you can still get
checkmated end game
and this is more of a reminder to myself
for all the times when i just ignore my
opponent
straight b-lighting for my king in an
end game where there's only like three
pawns left and i just get checkmated and
i'm like
so what happened you know and it goes to
show that in the end game the king can
be used as a weapon that's what sagar
did he brought his king forward
and he could have kept doing that
unfortunately he moved his pawn too soon
dropped the pawn
he still won the game so it's two to one
oh we have one of these fashionable
lines look at that bishop
nemo that's a great piece and even
though white is down upon i've seen the
likes of
mickey adams and others reminds me of a
grenfell reversed
yeah no that's a that's a good call it's
a good call but look at this this bishop
is so strong
and i always enjoy these positions from
white's perspective
because the pawn is irrelevant in the
current position you can play f4 there
it is protect this knight in the center
your bishop is so powerful keeping the
bish1c8 stuck in place
i really could not recommend this
position for black but maybe eric is
more familiar than i am and knows how to
deal with this
yes i mean i i don't think this is
eric's style position you know we talked
a little bit about how eric has been
playing very timid chess
um in his past three games but he's not
a timid
player by any you know standard and
i think getting into these positions um
unless it's unless he planned this you
know i don't know that
this can't be too comfortable for black
because i i definitely feel like
white is going to be always on
the the plus side here i really like e4
here actually
um as i was saying this i like e4 here
for white because you can't play d takes
e3
you get another amazing pawn to the
center i mean you're blocking off your
bishop a little bit but your knight can
always move and you always have e5
um wow i like that move a lot the e4
allows you to sacrifice your knight
because you want to put your pawn on the
e5 square so that was a cool
tactic there instead sagar i think we
understand his
decision making he wants to play brook
did he won and get his pawn back and say
my bishop my knight
i have the better pieces on the sport
here um got rook f2d1
yeah that looks like a juicy one
that's a juicer right there yeah that's
a juicer exactly let me just take my
pawn back why not
um i think the position you know you see
the evaluation bar i'm looking at now
off
the side here that it says about level
slightly better for white but from a
practical point of view
these positions are always difficult for
black to play because this bishop is so
strong and if you ever play bishop c6
you ruin your queenside pawn structure
so
it's just about the quality of the
pieces not the quantity at this point
for sure yeah quality
quality over quantity
yeah it's even material if you play
bishop b5 and take this knight then
you're left
facing off against this bishop for the
rest of the game so he's going for that
i guess
it just felt like the right thing to do
but i don't know i still think white
retains the edge the bishop is stronger
than this knight here
yeah i i think that this is one of those
positions where being white is just
awesome because you know you have very
active pieces but
um if white doesn't play carefully black
can um
snap back and take some control of the
center again with work to da
and whatever the the b7 pawn is actually
protected now so you also have like
chess play rook c8 so i'm actually kind
of curious to see what sagar is going to
do in this position
um because there's not like a clear plan
for white so it's kind of one of those
positions where you sort of have to wait
around and not make your position any
worse
yeah that's true because you know if you
move the knight too quickly you can drop
his pawn e2
and queen d6 saying all right now if we
trade queens my knight is happy to move
out the way
because i fork your rook and your bishop
and also hit this b7 pawn so
i actually really like this move queen
d6 and now the question is for eric
do i want to trade queens i have no
choice so how am i going to trade queens
the black queen can't move anywhere
to avoid it yeah um i mean here
queen takes a seven not pretty natural i
would say
yep i'm actually really curious as to
where like i think bishop to f3 after
and then just finding a nice spot for
the knight there's quite a few
right we have e5 we have uh potentially
b6 all those squares are
potential for the knight but you do have
to protect your e2 pawn
yeah good good reminder because we would
like to move our knight to a5 or
something like that which
is playable in fact because the b7 pawn
is weak but i like
as you said bishop f3 or rookie one some
kind of move that just defends this pawn
and then our knight is free to go i like
bishop f3 though you're right because i
want my rook is tied down to this rook
so bishop f3 says
in the event the rooks get traded my e2
pawn is still defended
yep for sure uh that being said knight
a5 does also look really good okay
bishop f3 is is very natural of course
just defending the pawn then we want to
go knight a5 next potentially
and that bishop's so powerful it defends
it attacks not a5 coming as
we keep talking about and how does black
play here if i gave
like two free moves they're not just
like stealing pieces you know what's the
actual strategy for black and okay
knight d5 does make sense i would play
king f2
no i don't even want to see a knight get
in the e3 square it may not join
we could also play uh d1 um just pinning
the knight which
might be really strong because you know
we have some e4 ideas coming and
black does have to respond to that and
then you can't move you can't just move
the rook away well
actually okay you just move the work
away now this is this is the part where
like end games are so confusing because
you just move the rock away i guess you
can take and then take on e2
right um that's that's good catch by you
though because
a lot of people would think they can't
move the rook because you dropped the
pawn but the e2 pawn loses defender when
the bishop takes on d5 so
you're right the rook can move but where
to right if you move your rook say to
here
my knight comes into d6 potentially
hitting your rook hitting your bishop i
want to trade one pair of rooks for
white
so i think 95 now get that night out the
way
this looks like very unpleasant position
for black
yeah this um
does not look very comfortable i think
95 right now we've been preparing to
play 95 by defending the
the e pawn and um you know perfect spot
for the knight the rook can pretty much
only go to d6
and can i take on i'm wondering if i can
take on d5 because there's background
checkmates
and if you take with the pawn on d5 you
get stuck with an isolated pawn and a
knight against a bishop so
it's a little deep but like in some
event like this where you try to
trade trade you can can't take with the
rook because the background checkmate
you have to take with the pawn
and hey that's an isolated pawn and i'm
happy to play against that c7
all this good stuff very true but what
about
you know afterward d6 i mean the knight
can't go anywhere right because like you
said there is the background check made
so what if you could put more pressure
on it
in in some way that's a really good call
that if this knight were to move i would
take in background checkmate you
but e4 the knight would go to square
like e7 or b6 to stop the
the mate so e4 is tempting but perhaps
not entirely accurate
we could try to undermine the notes okay
well he played e5
i was supposed to just f5 maybe but um
i mean e4 is very natural move too i
think he first perfectly fine
yeah knight b6 sort of force because
after the trade rook c7 is the movie you
want to play and if the knight was on e7
it'd be under attack
and the b7 pawn now at least the knight
is safer but rook c7
actually still might just win material
your rook gets to the seventh rank
and how do you protect both f7 and b7
uh i think the call is you don't i guess
you play f6 that's at least true yeah
that's and then where does this knight
go so this could get kind of awkward
very quickly for white but
i think rookies is objectively a good
decision it just becomes hard because
it's tactical you might make it stuck on
the f7 square if you put your knight in
there
so he does it i like it eric is
up a minute
yeah i would prefer to have the white
pieces in this position for
sure but that minute on the clock that's
getting me a bit nervous knight f7
is my knight ever going to get out of
there because
look at that doesn't have any square to
get to from
f7 no safe squares there that could be
too much of a risk and he's thinking
well can i get away with it
yeah i think after f7 knight f7 rd7
uh rook takes c7 special takes seven i
maybe this knight d8 yeah or 96
i think the knight does get out but
sagar is spending a lot of time on this
move and that makes me nice he doesn't
wow he does it he's brave and he goes
for it because
as you said if the rook trade happens b7
is defended but the knight gets out to
d6
and if not for the rook trade this b7
pawn is hanging this bishop maybe go to
g4
to hit the e6 pawn hey this is uh
looking pretty interesting here
for sure and where else can you rook d3
there's bishop e2 think about what
changes with every move played
your rook gets in your bishop's way i
will trade bishops and
i think bishop v2 look looks good yeah
bishop g4 also but okay here he goes
he's gonna take he's gonna bring his
knight out and then watch out for this
king getting checkmated
this is going to be intense i'm going to
see uh
potentially rick d7 maybe just
trying to keep things complicated
yeah trading the rooks off makes you
feel a bit safer this rook is very
strong here but white is still better as
you were saying you know the knight gets
back out to
the d6 square or to d8 honestly both
look pretty
tempting and i feel like white might
even win a pawn in some of these lines
yeah i think that's what i'm like mostly
worried about is that also bishop takes
b4 and then you suddenly get double
pawns
on the b file and on top of that the b7
pawn is still hanging you know
yeah and i guess you know rook takes a3
is the obvious move in quotes but rook
d7
he does go for it but now knight d8 hits
both pawns and there he goes bishop g4
i think which wins this pawn on e6
this oh no you're not strapped wait the
knight is fully
knight's trapped okay f5 saves the
knight for the moment but just
you can take and then play king e7 and
at best
you uh oh oh i mean there was e5
and then that yeah so you win a pump but
this is still good for black
yeah it's still so quite a comfortable
especially now now white's actually the
one with the um
isolated pawn on e4 right i mean not
that it matters that much because it's a
minor piece
end game but you know white will still
be tied down to protecting
that pawn for a while wasn't it
wait wait what ah
wait he just moved the king the king
just won the pawn
time trouble does bad things to people
but he was trying to get his bishop to
b7 i understand his plan but
you know i think that sauger's like lack
of online
experience is coming back to haunt him
here this is paul was hanging for quite
a few moves too so i was
huh okay should be two knight c7
yeah or knight c3 that's even more
active than start pushing this one
f4 okay yeah this is gonna be a win in
the bag for eric
just push it push him quite and
yeah it's a very straightforward
position um
for for white for black to play sorry
let's
be a bit careful because this b5 pawn if
i get to capture that
then maybe i have some chances to draw
this but i'm already looking at
sacrificing it i know that
i shouldn't but i'm tempted to so 96 is
a way better
move king e4 but can i get this pawns up
king g3 king e3
no knight check and then pawn push yeah
all right 94 oh
pom po straight away also works yeah 94
it's like almost soup small oh that's it
okay it would have been stalemate if not
for that h-pawn but oh
he's going for checkmate yeah wow
wow wow wow that's really sad turn of
events there for sagar because he was
playing
extremely well and this uh will be our
final game before taking the halfway
break it's a halftime in the five plus
one portion
but it just must be upsetting for him
because he was out playing eric he
pushed him back
he traded those final pair of rooks he
was having a nightmare d
attacking two pawns and then he just
slipped for one turn he moved his king
which he wanted to do in the end game
but he didn't seize the moment and that
allowed eric to
take a two-game lead yeah for sure i
mean
sagar was playing really well he's
definitely picking it up after
the last two after the two losses he had
at the start
and you know this is this is pretty much
he's he's getting warmed up i think he's
getting warmed up i think he's ready to
go
and in my opinion
eric needs to maybe play less timid play
like his normal self and just
really just be himself you know he's uh
he's a very aggressive player he can be
extremely powerful in tactics and
there's no reason to not show
that off in this match currently i mean
the last game
he played well for sure but he missed a
lot of tactical potential
yeah um in the opening and then sagar
played the rest of the game really well
so
definitely a lot of chances a lot of
exciting chess coming from
both for sure we're gonna take our quick
break and return we'll get back to this
match between two of the
finest ambassadors the game of chess has
stay tuned everybody you will not want
to miss the action
all right and we are back and
i'm glad to see that there is an
amazing meme oh we got pulled up here i
actually hadn't i didn't notice this as
we were going live but
yeah this is this is basically me right
now i'm casting as my apartment is is on
fire
um so yep yep this is a moon
i'm actually gonna make sure that this
shows up on twitter
i will make sure that is amazing shout
out to our producer for getting that up
in front of you all that is so funny but
you know it happens i've been commenting
a long time you never know what sounds
what sirens
coming from new york city you'll get so
i feel your pain i feel you
it's okay i mean nothing nothing serious
happened it was just you know
a practice drill so we're okay we're
fine but i am at least awake now and i'm
sure that
these players are very much awake now
too after having played
four games already i never realized
quite how slowly
five plus one goes you know as somebody
who
almost exclusively plays one minute
bullet just
i think we've we we've watched already
we i mean it was just a half time so
half of 75 is uh
you do your math again are you
struggling with your math 37
wait 37.5 okay i'm sure
that was not 37.5 i'm not sure how old
it was
okay um anyways there were only four
games played
um in quite a long period of time so
that is
the conclusion i've arrived at and
there's still going to be
a few more games played in the next 30
minutes
so um it'll be very very exciting oh wow
i
not listen learn never ask nemo for help
uh calculating anything got it
except for chess except for chess but
the math you know we're gonna say that's
too much effort no no
no i dropped out of school
not gonna lie two days ago so you know
i can no people can no longer make fun
of me for
having a math minor because i am no
longer doing my math minor
it's okay i don't have math skills
either but i don't even try see that you
know
sometimes you just pass that point and
we see
eric is playing a more principle it's
just like a you know spanish we got here
so this is your bread and butter
nemo right yeah spanish you're happy
central control for white black brings
the bishop out to g4 because white
didn't play h3
what do you see in this position um i
mean i've
always wondered in these positions if um
knight takes e4 works and the answer is
no it does not work basically
because of bishop to d5 so guys
it's not a free pawn okay don't take
that pawn it's it's very very much
poisoned
yeah just showing that quick you can't
protect both knights in the diagonal so
that would be a blunder
and yeah people ask that all the time
and it's good to show it just that a
bishop
hitting the two nights like that wins
material
and i mean this is a very very
stereotypical
um spanish position and
i am obviously you know quite quite a
fan of the spanish so
i am liking i'm enjoying this position a
lot for white i would say i don't think
this is
too comfortable like too much of an
issue for white at all honestly probably
not one of the
uh more critical eyes for black
yes and you know the center does look
well defended right now and i just in
being formed we got a raid from anna
chess so
good to see you hope you're doing well
thank you so much for
bringing everybody here we have a great
match ahead it's already
four games in it is between
international master eric rosen and
international master
sagrasha in the i'm not a gym speech
championship
four games in three to one eric rosen
right now we like his setup here with
pawns on
e4 and d4 but nemo what next right you
have the
good looking position but how do you
turn this into something more
well um i mean typical ideas in the
spanish or of course
you either find a way to attack on the
king side after closing the center so we
might say d5
i always like the idea of d5 and then h3
or
um h3 and then d5 both ideas work
maybe and and the idea of course is to
always push g4 but you usually want to
push g4 when the position
when the center is already closed and
uh or you've already set up you know all
your pieces for the attack so you're not
just weakening your king
so i'm definitely hoping that this
bishop c2 move means we'll see some
excitement
but also having oh there's your there's
the answer there's the excitement you
look for
we have pawns staring each other down
we've got the
x in the center here and which pawn do
you take do you take any of the pawns or
what's going on with this tension that's
always a question you have to ask
yourself
i don't mind your move g4 here i yeah i
like g4 but then i'm expecting knight
takes g4 i think
you know it's probably after g4 negative
g4 is probably
not the not not not like a solid choice
or anything like that and it won't be
played in classical but i think in blitz
it's always very effective
to um make the position more complicated
yes because there's a drawback to taking
either pawn if you take on d5
when the knight captures on d5 this
bishop is under attack and
black is happy to give up the knight on
f6 and imagine this bishop on e3 if you
take on e5
my knight captures back and there was a
pin so g4 was played and now
all eyes are on this g4 score will there
be a capture i feel like sagar is
a solid player more so than a you know
he's not trying to go for
tactical flare when it doesn't exist so
knight takes g4 i believe has
too much risk but he does have time he's
up half a minute on the clock
will he play knight takes g4 um
i think actually with the mount he's
thinking
i'm probably gonna say no i think he
takes d4 is probably more solid
and wait look at you calling his shots
here and now after knight takes d4 we
can trade some knights in the center
this bishop can end up on g6 and
i don't mind black's position because i
see the eval bar saying oh white is
slightly better
but that's right now and it's these
types of positions where
white's king gets under fire later in
the game so what has to be very careful
even though i like eric's position
i'm of the opinion that like these kind
of like once
white gets c takes d4 in and the bishop
g6 and then you get e5
in oh white's pawn
like push on the king side is so scary
you know
i mean there's not a lot of pieces like
left
well not a lot of pieces that's the only
two minor pieces that really
will be swapped off but um it's still a
very very scary kind of middle game
end game potentially for for black
because now yeah we see e5 white has
amazing control of the center
um after knight kicks e4 bishop takes c4
i
i really want to see a like you know an
f4 as well
even though that's a little bit
ambitious but i'm
enjoying this position as white for sure
yeah and one of the key themes of this
is pawn on c7 is
not a good pawn so if you can even
simplify rather than
uh pressing four which i like those
ideas with you know an eventual f4 and
pushing on the king side
if you can play some simple moves like
rook c1 and keep that pawn stuck because
black's main idea
is to say i don't that's a knight
position
c5 i want to rush my pawn forward to
chisel at your center because if i get
d4
e5 becomes weak i'm opening up the board
and only one of us
has an overextended kingside position so
that's
what i would be looking to stop if i'm
eric and he's spending time he's down a
minute on the clock
so that's concerning me about the future
of his position here
i just want eric to play like he
normally does you know
i mean uh he is
a very aggressive intuitive player
if he just kind of lets it all flow he
just like you know plays like he
normally does i think the moves will
come a lot easier to him i think
you know he he's got his hoodie up a
little bit he's uh looking a little bit
nervous
there is definitely quite wow
because now you have to take on poisson
you have no choice because if you allow
this pawn up to f5 you are in big
trouble so i do think we'll just see
e takes f3 i know that people think
that's illegal but when your pawn moves
two squares
and you can capture right now as if it
moved one hombus on e takes yep
i always forget about this when i do
puzzles always every single time i
it's it's just like but the thing is
when you see ampa song
on the board you're like i see on
poisson i take compass on you know
because it's so rare
but then when you're doing a puzzle you
never see the amphisong it's true
and look we have this pre-moved bishop
takes g6 he expected the episode to come
take with the h pawn you want to capture
towards the center keep your pawn on f7
which also covers white's
pass pawn you know on the e file and i'm
worried about this dynamic with these
pawns here i like white's position again
for now i like it but
c5 just what i was talking about this e5
pawn is the target
this center is collapsing which is bad
news for white's king
yeah i'm not too sure about that f4 move
i think i would have preferred something
maybe a little bit more solid because
that palm wasn't realistically going to
go anywhere so
a lot of pressure could be put on it but
now now white's king is looking a little
bit
weak the c pawn is looking a little bit
weak
um and you know black black has a lot of
chances to just
pile up pieces on the e file and the d
file yeah this c pawn is either
a great pass pawn or something that
black is just going to target and try to
win
and actually if you trade off pieces of
bishop f2
you know i have to calculate i'd use
bishop takes c5 and all that stuff but i
don't think bishop takes c5 works
because this queen is overloaded
defending the rook
well both works i should say and so
bishop c5 there's rook takes e5 and once
your queen lands on e5
my queen steals your rook in the corner
so this would just win material
for white so that's sad news for uh
sagar who would like to take that pawn
and if you can't take that pawn well
that's a healthy past pawn
yep this is um
definitely definitely a very complicated
end game and i'm i'm like starting to
like these complicated end games
because they take us out of our comfort
zone
um they give us something very exciting
to look at and and here
i think rick da is probably
my go-to choice just because
that rook hasn't done anything okay we
do see the rook d8 yes
you're playing tactically and i really
like it because rook takes d8 will
actually
lose this pawn on c5 by force rook d8
rookie one check
bishop e1 i'm not gonna take your rook
i'm going to take your pawn first
you always want to look can i get that
inter mezzo that's a check i will take
your rook next and then black steals a
pawn
so there are plenty of tactical lines in
this variation
i like rook d8 a lot and we see that
eric trying to figure out he takes on
e5 okay that makes sense rook takes d1
the c5 pawn
remains and this
is going to be um
the battle between is the pawn is the
password more powerful or is white's
king weaker
really like like that that is what this
entire position is going to end up
coming to i mean
the position bar the engine says is
equal
um because for the past one white has
a weak king right and if you play c6
that's the clearest illustration bishop
b6 stops your past pawn
while helping a checkmate idea or maybe
it's not checkmate but it's an attack so
i i practically like black's position
even though i
should like white position if it's a
classical game i'm taking white i'm
saying okay
i'm gonna avoid your checkmates and all
your checks but right now look at this
king move here i saw the eval bar dip
queen d5 check
good looking move and you can even just
go back and forth a bit
or queen c6 to block it but i don't want
to be passive that's the thing i don't
want to sit in front of the pond
wow well that is very aggressive king
move
yeah i don't buy that because even with
the king on g3 if you ever go c6 the
bishop would come out here so i'm not
enjoying this king marching forward i
don't i think it's going back this time
ah it's gonna be a draw
wow okay i i would have played on if i
was cyber and this is where the
inexperience online comes in you're up
six seconds there's a king on g3 out in
the open
i would have tried to win that game and
use time
up six seconds when it when it comes
down to these time scrambles um
any amount of time really really helps
you so
as a avid bullet player myself that
those six seconds
oh yeah you know you already know that
i'm going to prefer this up those
those few precious seconds right and
it's not the position was not
winning for black was even better for
black i think it was just kind of a
double-edged position where either side
could win that passport could promote or
white's king could get checkmated but
with an extra time
if you're a bullet player you know i
need to make the most of my chances i'm
down two points in this match
that could have been a game to cut the
lead or the deficit in half but i like
this line that
sagar keeps going back to the knight on
c4 and knight f3 we saw this a couple
games ago he did get his knight trapped
which was a sad thing for him but his
position was good
for sure i mean i think sagar is
playing these positions uh very
confidently
which i like i'm sure he's already
thought a little bit about what he
should have done better
like what he should have improved on
from last time so we're actually going
to a position we've seen before
and um if you missed the first game
between eric
and sagar in this position well sagar
really popped off
so that's actually where he got his his
one point
so and queen d2 played this time instead
of queen d3 so that's a
a little of a nuance here the queen on
d3
may be more susceptible to a bishop d7
to b5 so
let's just park the queen on d2 and
actually that allows rook c4 to be
played maybe that's the biggest
difference of all
is that rook c4 if he wanted to win the
pawn in this manner
could have been played and there would
have been no pin on the queen on d3
so but okay he goes rook to d1 and we're
back to where we came from
in the other yeah this is
looking very very familiar yes it is
indeed and actually
i wonder what eric did during the break
and we can ask in the post-match
interviews because
i would have looked at the opening i i
don't think he felt truly comfortable
here
but he's going right back to it so i i'm
curious if he actually
looked at this at all or if he just said
i i was able to hold him off as best i
could let's just go back to it
yep this just looks amazing for white
this knight this rook this bishop this
rook coming to c7
this pawn on b7 is a problem this pawn
on f7 is a target
you couldn't ask for a better position
nearly 20 moves into the game yeah and i
do think you know
it's actually very interesting that eric
got back into this opening
despite how the first game went because
i'm sure it wasn't very comfortable for
him
and we can see how sagar is um
using has only used 30 seconds for his
first 20 moves you know and that's
that's definitely great okay a little
bit of a deviation here right am i
yeah yeah the queens came off in a
different manner it's
sort of the same but yes it's not
exactly the same and you
made a point earlier the pawn e2 is
under attack maybe just bishop f3
looks strong king can come to f2 protect
that pawn first and then
continue your path forward in a bit but
uh something you just said there about
how
cyber had only spent 30 seconds that's
the biggest thing to me is
i cyrus shown that he's not that
comfortable in the blitz format not yet
maybe he's getting
it under himself or maybe he's finally
finding his form but i would try to use
the clock as a weapon as best i can if
i'm eric
and by going right into sagar's pet line
you allow him to make these 20 moves
quickly
and then now when he's thinking he has
plenty of time remaining to figure out
how to proceed wait is there not just
bishop takes e2 here
there is but then rook d8 check this b7
pawn hangs
oh rookie a that's that's probably what
was missed and
that's you know it's like you take this
pawn rook dhx you assume
oh i have to take first but you're right
rookie eight first makes sense
and if i take you take back b7 is
defended and even here white can play
rook c1 rook c7 and i don't think
white's any worse but you're right that
that pod can indeed be captured
i mean i think i think eric's now
thinking can i
or can i not yeah it's it's one of those
moves where it's probably fine right now
but you want to think
where that takes us in the game because
you do not want to win this pawn
if it costs you this pawn on b7 because
the queen side majority
will be easier to push the king is close
to the pawns in the center
and that's why eric ultimately decided
on king to f8 but he's just going to
have to suffer for the foreseeable
future i think rook d.a here too
um is very very similar to
the rook d8 we would have looked at
after bishop takes e2
yes and well i think you can do the same
thing take rook c1 try to get this rook
to c7 that's
where my eyes are taking me and once
your rook gets to c7 black's in big
trouble
for sure we might see king takes e8 here
and then if rook c1
oh okay we're just securing the e2 pawn
first
i mean white's seeing no rush right like
he he has all the time in the world to
um
play roxy one rook c7 yeah and even
actually if the knights
and the rooks come off the board white
is still much better so for example if
you play knight d7
and i trade your bishop takes so this is
what might happen
and the rook comes to c1 and you'll rook
c8 we trade everything white still is
better because this bishop is an
active piece your bishop will be on c is
a defensive piece so i wouldn't be
surprised if we see all that
but i guess cyrus says hey actually i
have a tempo to use
your brook can't move yet the pawn on b7
is hanging so i like the way he's
playing this
yeah oh what what
whoa whoa whoa that's a pawn that's
right
here rook c3 but there's rook to d3 yeah
rook d3 just blocks i'm trying to look
at eric's face here
the guy is so stoked he doesn't respond
to anything
like he's not even he just is acting as
if it's just
another move in a normal game of chess
but he did just drop a pawn but
sagar on the other side he just kind of
perked up in his chair there he's like
yeah okay
we're gonna get a win we're gonna go oh
yeah let's go let's go i see
i see him yeah yeah he's he's ready to
go
all right this is a match we're in the
thick of this thing here and
that was a big oversight by eric but it
wasn't a one-move blunder
i don't want to call it i think the
pressure got to him and the pressure not
of the match overall but this specific
position i think he needs to change this
if i were his coach i
definitely agree we went to the quicker
time controls i would say eric maybe
don't play this line or just here's
something you can do within this line
that makes your life easier but eric
right now
eric's probably thinking oh no my pawn
in his head
but actually like oh no my pawn for real
oh no
not the [ __ ] this this check here
would win the a3 pawn if not for rook to
d3 and
all right we're gonna see rook d3 played
and i think sagar is just going to
convert this end game it doesn't seem
like it's
one where black has too many chances but
weirder things have happened and he is
only
one pawn so it's uh not came over just
yet
yeah i mean these are the kind of end
games that you actually have to play a
little bit accurately in order to win
it's uh
the the the d-pawn is not a pass spawn
it's actually an isolated pawn so
now the plan will be to you know
potentially create the past pawn
uh on the queen side because you do have
a palm majority there
while at the same time not losing your
d-pawn
yeah it takes care of both right your
d-pawn is not protected the bishop can
come to c4
and once this happens the b-pawn is a
pass pawn but it's also a decoy oh i
like
okay now it's just a pass pop not even a
decoy you're going to put your pawn to
b6 the king will have to sit in front
and then white's king will just march
over to the king side
and that's sort of what i meant by
decoys you don't even need your b-pawn
to stay on the board forever
as long as it distracts black's king
long enough for white's king to dart
over to the king side
yeah this is um one of the positions
that i
think sagar is going to pick up
and you know the success of this opening
just goes to show that
maybe eric does need to choose another
opening
um and as we're going to
go into an even faster time control i
think that'll be even more crucial
because sagar
having being up two minutes at 40
seconds against
eric wow
yeah that speaks for itself doesn't it
that definitely does itself
and i'm i'm one of those kind of people
who whenever i play somebody
i'm looking at their clock like the
first thing i see is
their clock because uh you know the
position is a lot of things but
if you lose on time you lose the game as
well and this is maybe not the best kind
of way to
introduce chess to perhaps newer people
but the clock is definitely very
important
well that's true in most sports as well
right if you're down a bit you know you
you might run out of time and you can't
catch up so i mean look at this this
king is
caught king e7 king f8 this king is
going to just
hunt down and win all these pawns this
seems like a very straightforward win
and what you're saying about the clock
though it's true that i think eric needs
a more
double-edged opening to try to take
advantage of the fact that sucker
does not play that much online chess and
that he may
find himself in time trouble and may not
be able to play that high caliber chest
but
in time trouble that is but sagar wins
it's now three and a half two and a half
we have ourselves a very close match
and soccer now gets the black pieces and
just to look at the clock this might be
our last five minute game so if this
game goes
as long as the others have this will be
our final game in the longest time
patrol
i'm so perplexed by this queenie too
move yeah i don't like
i feel like there's a lot of better ways
you know to get the style of a position
um and then queenie two just feels like
one of those moves where it doesn't
really
do anything apart from defend e4 but
even then
i would have preferred to have just the
pawn d3 to protect
e4 so right and if i'm eric i'm thinking
about this because he's playing the same
openings
and there was that break i'm like wait
did vidit
call up sagar and just like give him
some opening advice like that's what
would be in the back of my head is
you know he's got some powerful friends
and if he just gets a phone call
hey uh you know maybe you should look
into this line that's what would concern
me so i would
be playing kind of i would dodge i'd be
dodging whatever preparation he might be
doing
and sar confidently goes back to the
same exact line
and he did have a good position in the
previous game before he blundered this
pawn and f7 with check that was
the biggest problem for him yeah i um
this is he's learned his lesson for sure
i'm actually really
interested in knowing um like what
what exactly is eric's plan for this
entire match because we've seen the same
opening a few times now right like we've
seen them repeat the same stealth
opening
um so surely something must change at
some point it's just a matter of i think
when
but so far this this this doesn't seem
to be causing white any issue
surprisingly this queen e2 move
which is very very funny to me a very
perplexing move
and eric sort of got the ideal setup
that he was aiming for
he would like to push his pawns over
here on the king side and say i have an
attack and that's why
cyro reacted with e takes at f4 he knew
that was coming and with a closed
position
the attack would feel even more powerful
because black's pieces were restricted
and
couldn't fight back so look at this d4
e4 this is the king's
gambit come to life but even stronger
the king is safe and castled
f4 is falling and once that falls the
open f file the bishop on c4 aiming at
the
f7 upon the black king i would be very
concerned right now for cyrus something
went wrong
here and i don't know exactly what so
these people are tricky
we're all just confused about what what
to do under queenie too
yeah it's somehow catching everybody off
guard and
eric is the one who's well had in the
clock so he's coming up with
this tricky opening that sagar is
struggling to meet
yeah and this is just one of those
things where it's like
he already knows what didn't work last
time so he's not gonna do it
however how do you improve on the spot
you know that's very difficult because
it's not like you have time to just go
off
and prepare a whole new repertoire
against
eric's e4 bishop c4 queen e2
so he's probably here just as confused
as we are 95 was a great move though
because
when you're getting attacked a lot of
people think i just need to put up a
defensive wall and i need to deal with
it directly
sometimes you can defend by attacking
your opponent so what
sagar is doing is he's striking in the
center first c5 now he takes d4 hello
moves like queen b6
knight c6 all this kind of stuff to go
after bl
white's pawns and this gives him the
counter play needed
so that white doesn't have the free
reign on the king side so i really like
what cyber did knight a5 knight on the
rims often are dim
but here it actually dimmed white's
attacking chances and look bishop e3 a
retreating move now you can play knight
to b4 go after this bishop
and all of a sudden black is creating
threats and now white doesn't have
that sufficient time to go for a check
mining attack
um the pair bishops in this position are
great for eric you know at some point
the e palm will probably move up and
then all of a sudden your paws are just
aimed at
okay well as i'm saying that uh sargart
knows he's got to step off those bishops
and this is now all of a sudden black's
king feels very safe right name right
now
yeah a couple moves ago i was like wait
that pawn enough seven is pinned the
piece in the f file and he's doing
everything right sagar is playing this
perfectly to say
i was worse and now i think i'm
completely fine i put my pawn on light
square if e5 my knight comes into the e4
square
and it's even material no attack for
white i'm not trying to claim that black
is better in this position
but black is definitely more comfortable
so the trajectory of the game has been
in sagar's favor
for sure i mean here 94 okay
um knight c3 is pr pretty natural we
still have to develop that night it's
almost
we're 17 moves and we haven't developed
the night on b1
so it's about time right next week it's
about time it's about time i mean
i always like to tell people and you
know as coach and pakchan i'm sure you
tell them a lot too
try to get all your pieces developed
before move 10 or something but here we
are
all right move 18 knight finally moved
and it's immediately gone
well it's important to note why sucker
took the knight rather than the bishop
if he took this bishop note that this
pawn on d5 is on a
light square this bishop cannot on e7
can't defend this pawn on d5
so in the event that is a knight against
a bishop this knight would try to
eventually come to c3 a queen to f3 and
attack the pawn so
this is why it's easier for black to
defend queen d7 now
just connect your rooks maybe rook c6 i
think that black is completely fine and
there could be a future where
actually soccer takes over the
initiative because this bishop on e3
on the dark squares is defensive
covering the pawns later in the game the
bishop on e7 could be used as an
aggressive piece
yeah i mean this is one of those
positions where it's like super super
solid
um we both have the same
color bishop so uh going into
end game that would just mean that it's
realistically a draw because
there's not no significant weaknesses
anywhere however
that being said it is you know a blitz
game so there's gonna be
probably some action coming up soon as
players run a little bit lower on time
eric is up a whole minute
and a little bit more so that's what
that's what's got me a little bit more
concerned i think
i think sagar is like really trying to
find his footing in this position not
that's like a very difficult position to
play but
whenever somebody uses a lot of time to
spend on the on any position just
it just goes to show you know um
they either have something amazing
planned or it's just not one of the most
comfortable positions
yes and you know he plays rooks what
bishop before
no oh whoa whoa
rook c3 i get the intention you're
trying to double the c file but
let's see eric's face
his even react how's that possible
oh no my rook yeah how is it possible
that he doesn't even react
like that was that's he walked into a
pin
he's so casual about he's like ah well
that happened i guess
yeah it's like it's as if this didn't
even happen to him it's like
somebody else is playing this game and
he just happens to be on screen but
i mean amazing composure he dropped his
rook and now
sagar he's ready to convert this win
this game
and even up the match score
wow what a turn of events in this game
here
and credit to sagar because he could
have just fallen victim to some kind of
checkmate
instead he fended eric off and he did
tenaciously struck in the center he got
counter play
and now i would play rook to g6 in the
near future to say let's trade rooks
you're never going to attack me
and yeah rook g6 now yep i think this
will be a very
uh easy pickup bye stacker and then
that's
that's absolutely incredible he played a
very solid game
nothing major particularly happened and
you know sometimes it's all chess needs
to be right you just wait for your
opponent to make a mistake
you catch them out on that mistake and
then all of a sudden it's
gg yep and the reason why this is so
easy now is because once the rooks get
traded black will play queen a1 and this
c3 pawn
is gone so bishop g5 that's a good
response by eric
he's in trouble no matter what at least
keep it a bit complicated
sagar under a minute on the clock making
movie h5 is a bit risky so
it attacks the rook but that could
backfire you just need to find
several accurate moves to put this game
away i think i would play h6 here
just to uh trade the rooks off
and there we go rotates g4 it's hard to
make a mistake in this position
it's black it's very difficult that's
true just do not touch this pawn on g7
yeah that would be the only mistake you
can make is giving up the dark squares
on the king side but with the pawn on g7
nice centralization pawn on g4 zone
attack this rook can do what the other
rook did rook c6 over to
g6 perhaps yeah sagar is going to
convert this one
yup for sure uh this is one of those
things where it's just like
ah i mean eric is just you know playing
along he's a little he's he's still up a
minute on the clock so you know he hopes
that he loses chances
but he knows we all know
there's very little chance in this
position for white however it is the
last game
of the five plus one anyway so it's not
like he's
missing out on anything by finishing the
game right that's good to talk about
match strategy because sometimes let's
say there were
30 seconds left in the 5 minute portion
you might just resign to get one final
game
if you feel that that's your best chance
but for eric no no he thinks the bullet
the quicker time controls because sagar
has been moving more deliberately
throughout this match but right now
sagar hasn't won yet
he's down to 28 seconds counting down if
he gets into a bullet scramble with no
time left
that's how things go wrong but i love
this move queen a2 rook c4
win this pawn all right no more i don't
even have to worry at first i'm saying
you know 26 seconds 25 it's doesn't he
just feel so bad playing these there's
just
zero counter play now the bishop can't
even move and like there's literally
nowhere you could go like
oh i just feel bad for eric you know but
like soccer
just played such an amazing game so i
really really really respect that
and i really respect how he just like
got that advantage just
crushed eric positionally being up the
exchange it's just
it's just incredible to see for sure yes
and
i often believe that mistakes like the
one that eric made by blundering the
exchange walking to a pin it's caused by
something earlier because of course he
sees that bishop before it can be a
response but
i feel like he didn't get what he wanted
out of the opening and that may have
been weighing on him a little bit just
do not allow by the way there we go so
sarge goes back because you don't
allow any sort of draw here so the queen
is coming to safety this a4 pawn can
push the b-pawn can push
and i think soccer's doing everything
perfectly at this point
yeah for sure b4
yeah breaking down the pawn chain d4 is
now weak as well that's a pass pawn
just a matter of time that's free yeah
perfect play by soccer yeah absolutely
amazing i mean
sagar looks like he's woken up fully
i don't know what else to say because
you know
eric was leading the match to to
to oh at some point and then all of a
sudden
um sakura like was fighting back and
and now and now the match will be tied
after this game and this is the part
where we talked about in terms of
strategies at the start right robert we
were talking about how
uh while you're playing this maybe maybe
eric thinks that he can just kind of
like
play solid stall out the match he's
already up two points and everything
will be fine but
i guess what he didn't expect his sucker
to suddenly
be like yes i'm gonna be the one winning
i know i'm down points
but i will win and that is
part of the part of chess that um
we all really like because there's
always chances and this this is this is
just incredible
well if i'm stuck i'm happy to get this
experience or he's playing in time
trouble and he's looking like a true
bullet player
he's spending almost no time for his
moves it is a completely winning
position
but when you don't play much online
bullet all of a sudden you get to 10
seconds
wait wait and then you blunder things
everywhere so uh sagar he's very
confident at this point his king is
coming in
he's going to promote his pawn and he's
going to be up rook
brook c3 and then take this bishop and
then get the queen
and i know some people like oh eric
should resign why is he not resigning
eric rosen doesn't resign and he
actually has been able to get stalemates
because he doesn't resign yeah there's
all those positions but
i'm actually you know if there was queen
to f1 that i feel like it's still my
trick but i'm sure sucker would not be
falling for that so
always worth the effort you know to try
to get stalemated you never know what
happens
i mean i can confirm that there have
been games where i
should have resigned like in world
championships and it's just been like
i'm not gonna resign and you just
swindle your opponent so
it's actually a very very um important
lesson to learn as well from eric to
just
you know play the game yeah i mean if
you resign you get zero points if you
end up losing by checkmate you get zero
points
you can't score if you resign so i think
that eric did the right thing
and speaking of score it is three and a
half three and a half we're gonna take a
break
and when we return we'll get to the
three minute plus one second increment
time patrol
it's excitement here between sagrasha
and eric rosen in this i'm not gm
speeches championship brought to you by
chess.com
all right and welcome back everybody
before we dive into another
really exciting portion of the match
between eric and sagar
let's talk a little bit about pogchamps
3 which
i know every single one of you guys is
extremely hyped for
so here we can see all the participants
in pogchamps 3
and let us know in the chat who you are
cheering for i mean i personally have
been
loki following a lot of these people
playing it's so exciting to see like you
know people getting into
chess it's such an exciting thing i've
played chess for 18 years of my life and
i haven't
probably seen this much hype um from
like the public audience
so i'm personally just like this is like
a big deal for me this is a big big deal
for me
um but yeah so i mean i've personally
coached michelle carrey
already um robert have you coached
anybody
i have indeed and you know i gotta say
if i had to pick a favorite it's ludwig
oh yes ludwig i mean ludwig we we've
we're familiar with ryan we've seen
ludwig not only play in pogchamps
we've also seen him cast pog champs
we see him cast he he is an absolutely
amazing streamer and
he's you know put in the work for chess
as well so i'm definitely
definitely excited to see his game play
this time and
i do actually want to point out that um
there's some people
including maybe maybe sir dosh is going
to be a very very very
strong player you know not not not
saying that
ludwig might doesn't have very good
chances of winning pogchamps
um i have seen sir dash spend hours
and hours and hours playing chess and i
think he's
personally said he was aiming to go for
like
1500 um by in by by the seventh
of february and uh i i when does
pogchamps three start exactly
i need the 14th if i'm not mistaken so
around valentine's day
all right around valentine's day you
know awesome none of us have anything to
do on valentine's day anyways
perfect um so yeah i mean
there's people with very big aspirations
in [ __ ] chimps and
i'm just so excited about it yeah you
know i won't name any names or anything
but some people are working
offline so you know of course people are
streaming a lot of chess but
i know you know from first-hand
experience some people may be
working really hard behind the scenes to
try to win pogchamps so
you know they're they're people putting
in their work it's a lot of fun to see
all these people play but
we're here today for this matchup
between
eric rosen and sagrasha i don't know
who's gonna win this match at first i
said
eric when we did pre-match predictions
but the last couple games sagar has been
finding his form he's looked excellent
he's
has really technical precision and he
doesn't give eric chances when he
gets the upper hand so eric needs to
find his footing here we have liftoff in
this next game
and knight f3 are we going to get this
same line again nemo
ah we might oh i think we're going to
get it
we're i think we're getting it guys um
it is three plus one this time
eric is thinking a little bit here so
maybe he doesn't want to repeat it i
mean if i was him i
definitely would not want to repeat it
however you know that choice is mine not
his so
i think we're gonna get it yeah the
problem is if this is your normal rep
oh queen a4 we have a different line but
if this is your normal repertoire it's
hard to
like say on the fly i'm going away from
this and he's playing a6 if queen takes
c4
b5 this way the bishop gets to compete
with white's bishop
so it's not a one-way street now both
bishops are happy in the long diagonal
but the concession is
this is a backwards c pawn so if i can
keep your pawn from getting to c5
white can claim a long-term advantage so
black is going to be looking to get this
pawn break
yeah i mean this is also i think the
main line of the catalog wait wait no
no that was wrong it was a blunder you
do not allow this the bishop is under
attack
it's night it's knight takes f6 right
yes god
okay now that the light square bishop
has been traded off okay so first of all
you don't really want to take on a6
because that bishop will get trapped
but that light square bishop is now
going to be an absolute monster and we
already saw how
much of a monster the light squared
bishop was uh when
black actually had a light squared
bishop right in the previous two
uh times they've played the catalan
already now that there's no more light
square bishop for black
that bishop has no contest and it's
going to be a pain for eric to deal with
for the rest of the game
yeah and if your sire what you want to
do is leave black with this bishop on g5
it doesn't necessarily mean that you
trade knights
you could trade these two pieces the
knight in the bishop but as long as you
leave black with this dark square bishop
that doesn't have targets
you're pretty happy so i would just play
knight d2
maybe knight to e4 knight f3 one of
these squares here get my knight over
the king side and
i think that white is has the most
promising position
out of the opening we've seen all match
yep
this is definitely something else i mean
we're gonna see the knight
possibly travel to c5 it doesn't
necessarily have to go there but that is
a very very nice square for i mean it is
an outpost
um is just you know square ware
no pawn can attack it right so
he did step one knight e4 but now he
now he goes step two knight c5 i was
waiting for it but he might be thinking
do i really want to allow that bishop to
cash her the answer is yes because the
c7 pawn is so weak you put a work on c1
do not trade queens on d6 don't do that
do not trade queens here
that fixes black's pawn structure you
are playing against
this pawn on c7
this is um you know we got we can see
either rick c1
or queen c2 i i kind of like quincy two
more maybe here because
if you swap off pieces it tends to ease
up the pressure for your opponent
right because oh well
we saw roxy one okay well it's fine
i would have personally preferred to
play queen c2 after a second thought but
nothing wrong with roxy one of course i
mean it's a very natural move to make
it's just
now i like if you if queen takes c5 d
takes c5 then you no longer have the
pressure on the c file i don't really
i kind of missed my pressure on the c
file and now there's even less pressure
on the cfl because you don't have a c7
pawn anymore so
right i think this has traded a little
bit more into equality that is not to
say that white's position is
you know it's not not good anymore but
it's just uh
probably queen c2 was the more accurate
choice from sagar
yeah this knight c4 there's like a
tactic which seemed unexpected
and it was a really good move by eric a
good find but white can still play rook
c2
rook c1 there's only one open file and
white can be first to it so i think that
what will remain better but you're right
it doesn't feel quite as powerful as it
oh i like this too because if you play
rook to c8
i can take and try to get my bishop to
b7 where i'll hit a rook and hit the
pawn so bishop f3
was actually quite clever
and this rook would of course love to
land on the c6 square
yeah well rook fca is going to be oh
yeah the problem with the bishop b7
lines where you know you could play rook
after ch to show very quickly
but if you take back with the rook here
there's bishop b7 which hits the rook
and the pawn maybe this is okay but it's
hard to play this in a blitz game for
sure
i do think directly too and then i mean
i'm not gonna try to like you know
contest the line but rick c2 it's also
very interesting end game where you just
down a pawn but you can probably hold it
because the rook's tied down to a2 but
of course it's very difficult to spot
these ideas um on the fly so yeah i'd
say
the hardest part is evaluating like i
know that i have compensation there my
rook is active europe is passive
but is it enough and in a split second
when you're now your white is down to a
minute
black is just a minute 15 seconds you
you don't assess it necessarily even if
you see it yeah it's always easier to go
for the lines that where you're just not
down material right i think as humans we
are
or as the way we've learned chess it's
always easier to just be like
ah i'm not down material therefore i'm
fine right
um nothing wrong with that mindset of
course but there's
a lot of things outside of material in
chess that impacts the game
absolutely and i'm worried about
speaking of material this pawn on
d4 it's on a dark square it can be
attacked and this type of position where
a knight can actually
be better than a bishop as okay i play
e5 without even a second thought and try
to use the dark squares
this could be a problem for sagar i love
the way the opening went he had a
big advantage but now things are turning
in eric's favor
yeah i mean e5 here um i would still say
that like you know d5 is a past pawn
however we all know that knights are the
best blockaders
of past bonds because it just sits there
yet
it still controls all the squares around
it you know so
um eric definitely has
a pretty solid chance of actually maybe
turning this end game around in his
favor i mean that the eval bar does say
it's still
fairly equal but a few raw moves from
two to remove from sagar and all of a
sudden he could could be completely in
black's favor
and if you get too aggressive for black
let's say moving f5 which is probably
good in this position
you have to watch out for your other
pawn the pawn chain is only as strong as
the base pawn
so this is a pawn chain here and the f7
pawn is defended but as soon as you make
a move like f5
your pawn on g6 could be weak but king
see that the engine did not like that
move one bit
so i'm wondering it seems like both
players are missing something but
it's hard to figure out what because the
position is pretty locked up not too
many pieces remaining oh
okay rookie hey check you have to
because otherwise you're okay i don't
forget they both only have 20 seconds so
we can't really
you know expect to see
perfection now yeah perfection
definitely go perfection here
where i rookie wait nights yeah that
rook is in danger
that is that is one very unhappy looking
rook
yeah you can play d6 at some moment to
keep it safe but you lose a pawn maybe
g4 but takes
takes his f5 to block the diagonal uh oh
it's gonna be hard to find this with six
seconds on the clock you just gotta go
a4
that's a reasonable move we're gonna try
to go a5 to kick this rook away
and look at eric down to 11 seconds he
doesn't want to take on a4 because
bishop e2 within
take on b5 actually that frees the rook
he made the move i said which is a
blunder
now the rook's trapped king b7 oh no
a takes b5 was needed uh
and i mean with that little time on the
clock
yeah it's gonna be difficult to find
these accurate moves you know i mean
it's hard enough finding them with in
classical time control that's going to
be
near impossible to find them the one
time control so
yeah and that move at the end there you
know a5
attacking the rook had a clear purpose
but if he was able to take on b5 the
rook would have been free
and now we see eric play c4 going away
from this
e4 bishops for queen e2 stuff that we
kept questioning
oh we're getting a sharper game from the
very beginning so black gets this
f5 e4 set up but whenever you push your
pawns like this the light squares
become more vulnerable but for now it's
just uh the opening stage
neither side is unhappy this is um
very exciting i mean soccer seems to be
quite well versed in this opening
otherwise i
there will be very little reason to push
up your pawns like this
as black so i'm going to assume he knows
what he's doing
i'm also going to assume that eric
that's what he's doing so this is going
to become a
very interesting fight i i really like
these more aggressive openings
it really leads to a lot of excitement
on the board
yes and look at this h4 making
intentions clear i'm gonna
attack your king but what i don't like
for white is these doubled pawns it's
not the biggest deal right now
but i feel and you can disagree with me
it's just maybe a personal opinion
that in blitz having double pawns is
really hard to deal with
because you'd like worry am i gonna lose
the pawn for instance pawn c4
can black play b6 c5 bishop a6 very
quickly and go after the pawn
these are like the worries that i have
at least and why i try to give my
opponents double pawns even if
it causes me to give up the bishop pair
yeah for sure i
i definitely would imagine that
um you know this is just
not the best position i
i'm not that there's anything wrong with
wise position but it just feels like
where's your king gonna go
it feels very unnatural to play this
position as white
in in in blitz because you don't have
easy plans right i mean your one plan
would be to possibly attack on the
king's side but at the same time
your king's still in the middle of the
board your dark square bishop is always
gonna suffer
and this is like okay well c5 is a very
good idea just trying to open up that
dark sword bishop
right but at the cost of the pawn
structure you may undouble your pawns
because you may continue taking here but
then you have the split pawns on the
queen side so
you're going to have a long term issue
regardless queen e7 is also a
interesting move saying you can't move
your pawn your pawn is pinned to the
bishop
so you can trade queens you can play
queen e7
i would keep the queens in the board
because white's king is in the center
yeah this is just one of those positions
where i'm like huh
king's in the center let's go queen
seventh let's baby play with the a i
mean at this point even if you
potentially
um well not that not that black's at
risk of losing a pawn or anything but
you're willing to give up a little bit
more just to keep white's k in the
center and white is still at least two
moves from castling on the king side at
this point i don't even know if he wants
the castle looking inside because
he's made the very aggressive choice of
playing h4 but that pawn will become a
weakness
if the rook ever moves from h1 right so
cyber thinking but this is i don't think
you can afford to spend this much time
here he is now
down over half a minute and he plays
queen e7
but if he was really feeling the
position he would just make that move
queen e7 just like you know what the
king in the center like we're talking
about
play this move and i'm not saying that's
how you should play chess generally when
you're playing classical time girls
don't just rush a move of course not
but in this format you're playing three
minute blitz you just gotta go
sometimes for sure for sure i mean this
is
intuition is everything in
blitz right you don't have the time to
sit down
evaluate calculate and i mean we've
we've talked about how sagar hasn't
really played that much online chess
um but he is still very very well known
and he he
he is around chess all the time so at
least some of these ideas are coming to
him
for sure and queenie five look he did
exactly return my queen default great
response by
eric rookie you do not take that queen
and help white's pawn structure so
rookie eight saves the rook from danger
on the diagonal it protects the queen
that's a move that you can comfortably
play pretty quickly he did so in what 10
seconds
he can't afford to spend 10 seconds look
at the clock right now he's under a
minute eric is a minute and a half so
these little moments they really add up
and i'm not trying to be overly critical
of course not cyber's a fantastic player
and
he just isn't used to playing in these
quick time controls
and that's what could hurt him but his
position is absolutely fine
for sure i think here maybe we just go
knight c6 yeah i like it
just kick the queen away yeah i mean you
definitely don't want to play queen
takes e5 because knight takes e5 and
that's just going to be
uh a very very strong knight on a very
nice square
yes yeah this is look at white's piece
of the bishop on a3 it's not really
everything i feel so scattered like i i
got like my
rooks are not connected we know we like
the rook bros my king's still in the
middle of the board my knight is
chilling on f4 i mean that night's
actually fine but like
none of the pieces are doing something
for the position like they're just there
you know we don't have a clear plan for
white
so it's it must be quite difficult to
play this um
okay well now we have h96 there's cheese
watch out for the cheese dude
if you take the queen on d4 you get
mated i'm sure that very quickly
bring up the analysis board here because
knight takes d4
knight g6 check takes takes the bishop
covers the mate uh the
escape score on g8 the rook will take
the knight when it moves and then that
is checkmate so there is cheese
do not fall for it he doesn't he's still
thinking
queen takes f4 is a good move because
there it is and take the queen now but
he spent so much time
he spent so much time to get here but
he's much better because of the light
square control the knight is way better
than the dark sword bishop i mean this
is one of those end games where i think
zagar can actually like
play pretty well with 12 seconds the
ideas become very simple right i mean
if the live square bishop comes out he
would just okay well
that was a good choice but the moment
the light square bishop comes out that
night is going to become a monster on d5
and there will be nothing that white can
do about that night so i mean
black now has a very clear plan and rook
d1 played the a2 pawn can be captured by
like what sagar does he's like i'm not
concerning myself with pawns over there
can't i really get away with it let's
just play simple moves that look strong
the 95 is also good because this bishop
will never get the full length of
diagonal movie rook rook b8 just do it
let's go
now you can even play b5 b4 if you want
the position is getting better and
better this pawn's under attack obstacle
bishop end game
simplistic but good for black yeah
and look actually eric's down to 15
seconds himself i don't even notice that
oh rook b2 clock moment knight c3 first
that's great rook b2 now
bring your rook in oh my god this
position is so
oh now bishop c4 92 check maybe
maybe 92 checks okay well both are very
similar
yeah so you can play 92 take on d4 put a
bishop on d3
it's good for black but the clock what
are you doing three i would have
preferred e3 but yeah oh e3 would have
been
e3 would have been sick okay bishop d3 i
would just do it two seconds you gotta
move you gotta move come on
oh my gosh point six second
move ah i lost some time
oh look at him ah he sits back just
oh he can't believe it he played
so well there too oh
that's just heartbreaking because that
would have even up the match and now
it's a two-game
lead for eric rosen it's so hard to play
with a plus one increment i mean the
plus one increment
exists but you know you still gotta
pretty much pre-move right
every single move yeah
wow oh my god that was an intense game i
mean sagar is
on form he is actually on form and
and that is very very exciting to see i
mean
played an amazing game which is very
unfortunate that the time is part of the
game and
you do have to worry about the clock
sometimes yeah that game was about what
five seconds away from evening the score
and uh sagar just took a moment there we
saw him
he was frustrated he calmed himself down
he's
clearly in this match right this match
is not away from him
but what we have been seeing is as we
creep closer close to the bullet portion
that's where eric will probably be at
his best and sagar has looked a bit
shaky
however there's several more games left
in the three plus one
this is sagar's time to make the most of
it
and let me just position right now solid
all right we have a typical c4 d4
setup where you control a lot of the
board but it's it's closed the position
is really
locked up right now
yeah this is one of those um it reminds
me a little bit of the kohli which is
what i play
and it's very very solid and it doesn't
really give
white an advantage but it's definitely
not a bad choice for blitz because you
have
very very simple moves to make you know
you go for this e4 plan you start
putting your rooks towards the center of
the board you maybe look at a d5 pawn
break
the ideas are not difficult and that's
sometimes all you really need
in blitz because
time but time exists and we we we found
that out from the last game
we're not seeing a philosophical
discussion if time exists or if it's
just a construct but
we see that sauer didn't need to waste
any more time to jump his knight in the
center but i don't like this because
after pawn takes
bishop c5 now both of black's bishops
are going to be excellent the rook on d8
is well placed
so i think that night jump was really a
problem for him now he's
going to have to fend off the initiative
that eric has
and chad is like time exists forehead
true oh
well i love you know riling up the chat
a little bit there so
let's see what's going on bishop d4
maybe
i could see a queen sack happening i
would think about sacrificing my queen
for the bishop and the rook but still
that's something i would never do but
yeah
for sure well look at the resulting
position right now black is just
marching forward so maybe objectively it
still was good for black but this
at least practically speaking doesn't
look very fun yeah i'm not sure if i
like this position
uh as late it just feels like everything
is on the background you know we
actually don't have a piece above the
second rank that's beautiful
and you have that one pawn that's about
to be lost so that's not going to be
very good news yeah
yeah i think there's raw in this game it
was going fine and then it just wasn't
going fine
in like two moves yeah that 95 move it
opened the position up but in favorable
terms for
black and black's pieces were situated
perfectly for it so
that cyber needed to time it better
speaking of time he needed to put a rook
on d1 and being able to counter
instead he's in this position where he's
losing on time
he's losing his pawn e5 it looks like so
he's in some big trouble
yeah he is taking his time to think in
this position
um i mean it's hard
it's i don't think the choice of playing
bishop takes d4 is the hard one i think
it's a realization that your position is
not amazing that's the hard thing to
come to terms with
and realizing you have to either play
queen to g5 or queen e3 to protect your
e-pawn
um and queen e3 just looks absolutely
awful because
queen takes e3 and he has to play it
because otherwise you just lose that and
it's really more like putting a bandage
on a bleeding wound because like
man those pawns are you talked about
last game how double pawns are just so
unfun in blitz games because you're
always worried about losing them and
these are
quite possibly one of the worst double
pawns
i've ever seen yeah the only good news
and this is a small bit of good news
is that you can't actually attack them
the pawn e5 it's
isolated it's weak but how do you attack
it you need your rook somehow to get to
the fifth rank
which isn't quite possible so i like
what sagar has done
all things considered his position has
been bad but the last bunch of moves
have
been beneficial for him uh the rook's
probably gonna come to g2
i mean the rook on a1 is tied down to
the eight oh
oh look at that tactical fine no i was
thinking the same thing i was like wait
how do i deal with rook d2 but rookie
one is so clever because once the rook
takes the bishop will capture back
and then the rook trade is offered and
the a2 pawn is defended so this might be
sire getting out of the woods because
this e5 pawn it's weak but it can't be
attacked
especially not in a king and pawn ending
yeah
i think after rick takes d1 or kicks you
one bishop takes two i mean we're taking
one bishop 61 sorry
uh we have roxy one just trying to keep
up the pressure but
soccer is like slowly easing his way out
of this and we can see erica's is like
you know biting his lip uh trying to
think of ways to
keep his advantage up but this is
actually not that bad anymore
right too bad for white i mean black is
still a little bit better but
yeah if you trade rooks you're not going
to win the game because your pawns are
hard to get so rook c3 makes sense but
king d2 now
your king just comes right to the center
attacks protects the pawn if rook d3
just king over to e2
and you keep your pawns defended so i i
really believe that sagar has made his
way out of this
i think his position is actually quite
comfortable and
the one big problem i would say is these
pawns are on light squares so if you're
not careful
at some moment some kind of bishop b1
bishop a2 and just
cutting down the pawns could happen but
he plays rook e2 instead which
feels more passive yep and here we're
gonna see
that king to e7
um i mean it's just going to become an
end game which will probably lead to a
drop
i mean time is the one thing i'm going
to be looking at now
we know uh sagar just lost the time the
previous game so he's probably well
aware of his own clock
i would play f6 i would say i you know
your pawns look ugly but i want to get
my king
up into the center of the board so f6 is
what i'm looking at in the near future
for eric okay i do think they're gonna
go for the draw here though they're
gonna go for the repetition here
you think so eric's up so much time i
would play on if i were him
i would play on as eric too honestly um
but eric has well maybe maybe now we'll
see something like
beef maybe b5 yeah i like that too
just trying to advance your pawns yep b5
and then if c takes b
c c takes b5 c takes b5 then you
actually have rook b5 and we can
actually go for the e5 pawn
that's a great point so g4 well i like
this too because you're creating another
advanced pawn which could backfire for
what look at this rook h8 coming soon
watch out for your h3 pawn
this looks very dangerous and you have
13 seconds
yeah i'm not sure about the bishop takes
g6 move
oh that's a good move rick h2 you can at
least save your pawn
and this e5 pawn is somehow still here
like
it should have been captured it feels
like eight moves ago somehow but you
could never get to it so king up bring
the king up yes king d2 is good
king d3 king e4 okay king c3
nice oh direct is coming oh great move
h5
take it over the pawn and then just try
to trade the pawns and then the rook
might even get around if you're not
careful this row can come to h8 into b8
so don't drop your a2 pawn
okay now he's dropping the eyes dropping
e3 and e5
or is the rook i don't like this way of
defending
it's so passive it's so passive king c3
give
your a2 one thing about rook end games
what's the first thing you learn about
rook end games robert
you don't want to be defending passively
yeah you don't you want your pieces
active a king d3 here
he actually might hold on qc3 back the
king is just going back and forth okay
shade go over kj go
bring that rook around honestly white
could somehow win this game if black's
not careful
i mean he he's been playing very active
maybe we might see yeah king to d7 and
rook the e8 then king
c7 and rook f8 you just keep attacking
keep going okay
okay that's also good okay rick faye now
yeah yep
now king d4 do not allow the black
unison oh no he made he
okay well black didn't play king to c5d4
okay don't take him
oh yeah that's the issue now rook takes
e5
oh okay well i mean he'll do it soon it
came before now
oh he's not taking on e5 i mean i guess
he really doesn't want to give up the
f-bomb
oh oh oh no and sagar is just like i've
had enough of this right now
but it's fortunate for him that it's a
time for a break they're midway through
the three plus one portion but for a
sagar you gotta feel for the guy he's
playing really well and credit to eric
because he kept up the pressure
throughout that whole game
sure there were some moments where maybe
there was something to be done but he
couldn't break through
he realized i'm not winning your pawns
but he kept creating weaknesses in
sagar's position
and he didn't have enough time to hold
on for sure i mean part of chess is just
annoying your opponent enough until they
eventually aren't able to keep
protecting everything right so
you know eric played a very very good
game and sagar almost held on
all the way to the very end but sally
time is not on his side today so
yeah well it is time for us to go to our
break we'll be back soon with more
action from this saga shot eric rosen
i'm not jim speech's championship match
brought to you by chess.com
all right and we are back
for the second half of the three plus
one
um and we just saw some very very very
exciting games between eric and sagar
and all i want to say is maybe after
this break maybe sagar has
like freshened up his mind he's gonna be
very aware of his time because
he's had pretty decent positions the
last couple of games unfortunately
he has lost to the clock and that is
a very very unfortunate way in a way to
sort of like
lose in blitz but of course we all know
that's part of the game right so
however we are expecting to see um some
pretty exciting things
what are you predicting well it's just
very difficult to know like
how much time you use in certain
decisions because sagar is
playing great chess as is eric but i was
spending too much time
and some moments you just need to be
practical that a good move played
quickly
is better than the best move played
slowly and we say this every single time
it's hard to internalize that especially
as somebody who you know studies the
game their entire life you're like wait
i want to always find the best
move but when the situation arises where
you don't have time remaining to find
the best moves when you're winning or
when you have a good position
then you're like okay now i just need to
play quickly and sometimes
not overthinking is producing the best
chess for sure
definitely i hear you there um
i mean honestly in terms of playing
blitz and like these
longer time control strategies all of
these things
classical making the switch from
classical or even rapid into faster time
controls
is quite difficult because as chess
players right
like robert said we all want to find
really good moves but sometimes you
realize
hey sometimes i just need to find a move
and that may be what sagar needs to
realize in this moment i i have no doubt
at all that his intuition is amazing
maybe he just needs to trust himself a
little bit more
yes yeah we're about to see the next
game get underway and we'll see how he
handles this because he
is down three points he's still in this
match and i hope he doesn't
just start sacrificing pieces for no
reason but he does need to
get winning that's for sure get winning
i like i like the way you put it
i you know it's what else can be said he
needs to win games because he's down
three and eric
is the favorite in the bullet portion
but sagar is playing very well so he has
his chances
yeah for sure i'm excited
um and we'll get the games in just a
moment now and here we go
d4 played by eric so we saw airplane c4
and now he plays d4 we also hit e4
earlier and we're getting
a london system of course
now if you don't know about eric's
london
then you've probably been living under
a rock um this is definitely one of
eric's you know
favorite lines it's something that
you've definitely seen before
play by him okay this is actually a line
i've not seen before i've never seen
when london where the queen gets onto c5
yeah there are some lines where the
queen gets here but usually it's when uh
white
wins material because it's like a known
blunderline it's not this
this is perfectly good for black look at
this you've established your center with
d5 and e5
your queen is absolutely fine being on
the c5 square
and you can castle but if you cancel
kingside you lost the benefit
of doubling your pawns which is the open
file so i think sagar's handled this
perfectly
you know i might actually start playing
this line myself as black this is
looking quite exciting
it looks great i mean there's nothing to
complain about in this position
and for sure you can just develop your
knight to c6
or to d7 i'm not sure which is better
square he chooses d7 i guess to give
the queen more returning space to use
the c file potentially
at some point so i just prefer black's
position
uh very very comfortable stuff this is
um
we're gonna see the rook come out i
actually prefer maybe work to d8
just because i kind of want to push d4
at some point
however i don't even know if my idea is
gonna work and
yeah and i think in part knight d7 i now
that i'm thinking about it the knight on
c6 would be dominated by the pawn on c3
the knight on d7 has a future on the c5
square of the queen is to move out the
way
all right um we do see white just
relieving a little bit of pressure in
the center with e takes d5
i'm liking knight takes d5 here or maybe
even queen takes d5
i like queen 65 just because i don't
want to give up control over the e4
square i know that it won't amount to
anything
but just that thought of the queen of
the bishop lining up and turned checking
my king
makes me feel a little bit more cozy but
i also understand there's bishop c4 at
some moment
so there are going to be tactics all
right
knight e4 um this position is just so
unfamiliar to me i'm like trying to wrap
my head around
how everything this position is going to
work out maybe maybe we play
knight takes e4 feels like an easier way
out where you just like ah
let's just start swapping pieces going
to that end game
um but i'm not sure if black actually
maybe wants to keep up the pressure in
this position because i definitely feel
like black is the one with a little bit
of an edge you know
he's the one with a little bit more
initiative yeah i think this pawn e5
is the best situation and i see the
evaluation bar go crazy
and then it goes back down so there
might be something available here but
there's some maybe
tactics involving a knight takes e5 so
if you take on f6
first that's probably what it was and
i'm only helped by i see the evil bar
going up and down
otherwise i mean rook 81 looks like a
perfectly normal move and that's the
biggest difference
when the players are playing they have
no idea if they miss something unless
they spot it
but they're not informed that there's
something available the biggest
difference between
seeing an eval bar or knowing it's a
tactic is well you have to know it's a
tactic before you can play it
definitely and here i mean
we're just going for a solid gameplay i
kind of like this choice
coming from um you know
this this opening choice from soccer has
been absolutely great he
is however still using quite a lot of
time but i mean eric sees a lot of time
here too just white doesn't really feel
it doesn't feel like white has a lot to
do in this position
so that's probably where all the thought
is going into i mean how do you how do
you improve your position here right
i do like that last move but black can
just move this knight out the way knight
c5 was the choice
hitting the bishop protecting the pawn
on b7
and i don't know i feel like both sides
can be
comfortable in this position bishop b5
looks reasonable this rook can come to
say d8 or something like that
i'm not sure who's better yeah rook aca
here maybe
sorry i just had that cough there uh
rook c8
is possible for sure and yeah that makes
sense you protect
over protect the knight and if this pawn
ever thinks about going to b4
your rook's on a good line with this
pawn on c3 so rook c8
definitely makes sense to me
yeah and uh oh wait
e4 this is very aggressive
that's a pin so if you move the knight
you lose the rook but perhaps there's
like a counter pin with queen c4
the e4 pawn captures an f3 you lose your
knight your bishop on g4 rather so
or you could also play b4 which attacks
them
that's yes that's true that knight is
very important
yeah pretending because you can't
actually take on f3 right
since um like robert said they're nice
yeah
nice i honestly wasn't even looking at
the rook and the eight but now that you
suggested and then the move happened
like oh e takes f3 isn't the threat
it's a pit yeah it's a bit that means e4
was never a good move to begin with
yes for sure uh this is
a last pawn for black sadly yeah i think
you just have to
accept that fact you can't keep spending
time though look at this it's you're
losing a pawn
and you're down 35 seconds so just
play knight d7 or something i'm not sure
if that's good but you play the move and
hope that you can you know gather enough
strength in the position to
fend off white's position oh what
i'm looking at sauger's face nope he
shakes his head he didn't see who was
hanging
he's like me don't play like me don't do
that
yeah he just didn't see the rook was
hanging
i mean to be fair to be fair it's not
very obvious
um the queen is on a very odd square on
b5 i mean you would hardly ever have a
pin pawn on e4 right like i
this is probably one of the first time
i've ever seen a 10 pawn on e4 but
oh that was a puzzle rush room in there
for sure
it was and it's a full extra rook if
you're cyber you need to resign you need
to get more games going yeah you need
this is one of the strategies as well
for these kind of formats where there's
still 15 minutes left in the bank for
games you got to play as many games as
you can or at least try to get those
games in
that's true and he's back to his bishop
g2 lines
getting the bishop on the longest
diagonal and eric
spending a little time before playing
knight f6 so let's see if cyrus can
whoa b5 stopping any kind of c4 this
is still it's a true opening players
like vladimir kramnik played it so
you know that it's i play this line as
black i like it a lot
you you basically say no to the catalan
you say no c4 for you but at the same
time by extending your pawns so far they
could become targets but i do think this
is
a good strategy by eric because sagar
has been way too comfortable in those
catalan lines
for sure and c3 this is a good way of
playing against this a5 protecting the
pawn now you can just play knight to
d2 he takes on v4 which gives you the
outside pass pawn
and if you can get your knight to b3 you
stop black from playing c5
black would like to play c5 so you don't
have this backward pawn
i really like your explanations of all
these openings i'm learning too
just like i hope everybody in chat is
learning how to play all these different
openings
honestly eric's openings have been
um maybe apart from apart from his e4
bishop c4 queen e2 line
but that that one that one is a little
bit unique all of these other openings i
feel like have been super instructional
today
yeah and i would say that sagar is
handling it very well
uh for the most part i think he's been
doing uh
he's holding his own in the opening
stage but he just spends too much time
in critical moments and that's what's
holding him back and
bishop c4 closing down the c file it
makes sense i can just move
oh i can't go knight to d2 i dropped my
e2 pawn so i should not do that
just rookie one to defend the pawn i
thought the rook could also go to c1 to
try to
say if i kick your bishop down goes this
c7 pawn but either way we're getting a
tactical position now
i actually really like bishop takes b3
before knight e4 because then i can just
get c5 in so now i'm wondering if
like i think it's very important to keep
control of that c5 square right i mean
c5 is always a very thematic palm push
in the catalan even if this is not quite
the catalan
um yes yeah no
you're not getting it right this bishop
and g2 is going to open up this knight's
under attack this bishop is under attack
and now knight takes b3 of course i
would have preferred knight takes d2
yeah he didn't want to give up that
bishop and now like especially because
black
is never ever ever going to get c5 hand
as long as
white you know kind of just plays rookie
to c1
knight knight c5 maybe and that c
pawn is looking really weak of course be
careful you don't want to take c7 here
because your queen will be trapped after
work to c8
i'm going to show that really quickly
because it looks like a free pawn to
most but where does that queen go and no
squares are available
to your queen over here so the queen is
trapped in the spot
that's kind of crazy honestly yeah
knight c5 played the point i think is
that white will play for e4
if you take on c5 i can just take back
but there is a moment i can play e4 and
help my bishop
and alternatively i can say wait i have
an outside pass pawn
and i don't mind pushing it up the board
yeah this is um looking pretty comfy for
white honestly
this is this did not go very much in the
favor of eric and i also think this is
just one of those
positions that nobody really wants to
play as black because you're out here
defending
you know you only got one minute o'clock
defending is always more difficult than
attacking
in blitz games just because
you don't have natural moves to make you
have to always think about what your
opponent's doing you're always trying to
respond to them so that's very difficult
yeah knight c4 that makes sense you say
you're like you don't want to sit
passively you don't want to defend
but here that's what i was hinting at
earlier e4
the knight needs the defense of the pawn
so you're just trying to take on d5
and remove the guard
but i guess he'll play you can still
play e4 like you can just go and try to
open up this bishop the bishop can also
reroute to f1 eventually
to use the new diagonal but instead we
see b3 which is also a very good move
yeah um here knight a5
we're going to eric should be trying to
get that c5 pawn push at some point and
you know we all have the saying that
knights on the rim are a little bit
paper
so that knight is not happy on a5
we have also talked about however about
how knights are the best blockaders
however you kind of have to combine
those two and be like
do i would i rather have my nine on the
rim while blockading or should it just
be
you know somewhere more active right and
i and this is one of those moments where
i wanted to be
a little bit more active right but you
do make a great point about the knight
blockade is a great block hitter because
it still attacks
over the pieces so the b3 pawn needs to
have an eye kept on it
and right now eric he's down on time
he's trying to figure out where does the
queen trade want to happen
i didn't want to take on c5 to allow the
rook in and for white
is it time for e4 is it finally time
to do it no e3 which does make sense
though he's trying to keep the position
a bit
tamer and now the king is on e7 i would
try to keep the queens on the board if
i'm white i would bring my queen back
that king is
in the center here and it's not going to
get checkmated
but it could fall victim to some kind of
attack
yes for sure and i think these palm
pushes are
we're just trying to get all the moves
out you know before before somebody has
to commit to something
what does they call like in chess when
you when you just don't want to make
your position worse
so you're just trying to like find those
moves that that are like
potentially beneficial don't really do
much but most importantly they just
don't make your position worse
yeah just those kind of waiting moves
yeah the waiting moves exactly and those
are hard to do it i think black is
taking over all of a sudden because
you can play for e5 you can play for
knight b7 pawn c5
you finally get that pawn break and it's
not that black is that much better you
have to be careful
but the position is favoring black the
trajectory here and look at the time
it's about even
it's getting a little better for black i
oh and we get the c5 that we wanted
yes and the thing is a lot you can't
take on d4 so there is a pin
to look out for with this rook on c8 so
you need to figure out how to move
forward here
for black maybe it's rook c7 rook c8 but
i guess not because the palm is captured
immediately
yeah i mean here for sure there is going
to be you know a bit of
like key f1 move the king over oh that
knight is going to look
absolutely amazing on c3 i just realized
that
yeah this is not pleasant but the thing
about the knight c3
is then the b3 pawn feels safer because
now it can't be attacked so even though
that's a great knight
you're not attacking the pawn anymore so
move this bishop away i think bishop f3
i don't even
want to give that up anymore and then
later in the game i'll think about
pushing this a pump but
of course don't allow e4 check yeah
oh i i don't think i love that because
it seems committal now
you're gonna have a harder time pushing
d4 but maybe this king comes to e5 you
push for d4
anyway and look at how quickly eric is
taking over this game
yeah there's definitely a lot of um
pawns on light square so pause on light
squares when your opponent has lights
where bishop can go either
can go in two ways you either
completely shut down the light square
bishop because all the pawns on that
color
or the light square pawns become really
really weak because they're on the color
flight skirt bishop you know all right
so um this is one of those moments when
i mean the position is objectively
speaking
fairly very equal but i do think white
has to be fairly
oh time clock clock clock clock there
was 55 there
uh rook if i would have been nice but
bishop you made a good point these pawns
watch out
0-7 give me one free move and i get
through pawns so king can go back to f6
but look at white
keeping the opposition do not take that
knight you hang your rook oh he lost
some time
he lost some time no oh
he was fending it off so well
it was going so it was a draw
and this is not the first time
this has happened oh no sorry
oh no no no yeah the time is not his
friend
it's not on his side and these games
have been
very close but eric has been
moving more quickly and he's been
finding the resources necessary
in the ensuing time trouble so well done
by eric and for sagar it's just
that's the kind of day it is maybe with
some more practice he'd be able to speed
up and
manage his time better but right now
it's been all eric rosen
yeah for sure i mean eric eric is
definitely popping off today with
um his his control of the position
really i mean
summer was having these great positions
but he wasn't able to
convert them and that part
is very unfortunate especially when
you're playing so well
but i mean i i just hope that this
motivates sagar you know he's a very
very strong player and
we've talked about how eric plays
every day sagar on the other hand we're
a little less unfamiliar
uh with his history of online blitz
chess so
honestly he's doing absolutely amazing
yes and you can tell that he hasn't
played much given that his rating
is like 20 50. oh he's way underrated
he's
so underrated for sure and what's
happened though in the last
it was three and a half three and a half
in the last five games eric has won
all of them in the three plus one time
control because
you start with less time when cyrus goes
in those deeper things
he doesn't have time remaining to figure
out the rest and
that's been the tale of the match right
now again i like sagar's position with
the black pieces
he's got his knight on d4 hitting this
pawn on e2 that's already
a really devastating tactic you can put
c6 you can play bishop h3
you have a nice bishop on g7 the opening
has gone
sagar's way
i think black is going to enjoy this
position
however he is down 30 seconds
oh no yeah foreshadowing what we
could see oh yeah it's a very good
position
for black i mean you have everything set
up for yourself bishop takes you too
necessary here yep
96 f5 things like that
you know the thematic moves we see
i like black's position there's also
some ideas with knight g5 and queen h3
if you're not careful
so already eric should be on the lookout
for that
and find a way to counter it
the thing is f5 though it's so easy to
play
like f5 knight g5 ideas he's spending a
lot of time on moves that
um i feel like intuitively he could be
playing a lot faster but i think
i think what he's doing subconsciously
is double checking and double checking
you know
but it's people who have played a lot of
blitz we just
instantly go because you know that's
that's kind of just what you do
and that's what happens when you don't
play regularly i mean i play
some blitz online of course but when i
play in classical tournaments longer
times
i spent so much time thinking if i move
that pawn is that going to create a
permanent weakness for me or is that
just a good move
and then as you said you're triple
checking the position
and spending too much time so f5 great
move he is now ahead on the clock
we'll see if he can score a victory from
a good position right now
he can play d5 he can play g5 he can at
some point play h5
he has choices here i like it great yeah
just go forward here
the major downside of playing f4 is the
e4 square becomes white but then you
have the
d-pad going to d5 so i do like sagar's
position here he's playing quickly he's
been confidently
and let's see if he can take it all
right
i mean here we have so many possible
moves
for for black kind of i kind of want to
start playing this like it's a king's
indian maybe go reckon 7 or a cafe and
just start
storming white's kingside i think that's
honestly the best um
wait for black to play just very natural
moves you know
you potentially have this open open fo
that is wow okay i mean
he's going for the attack yeah he's
going for the attack he's being very
aggressive
just just take take on g3 how do i
where's that knockout you know like i
could take on g3 you take back my rook
is in the right place
but then how do i actually go and
checkmate you
that's right yeah this is a very very
important question i mean
now the c5 could potentially be leaked
too so you could
play like throw in a rook c8 at some
moment yeah
that makes sense queen c6 actually just
attacks
something like that no nice little
double attack here
hmm it's funny because i want to check
with you along the f file but sometimes
the best attack is creating a second
avenue of attack instead of just
tunneling on the f-file let me make a
move like as you said rook c8 or queen
c6 or something of that nature
that could benefit black's chances
so cigar thinking here sorry he's
down under 45 seconds suddenly he has
half the time of eric and
this we've seen this one before oh yeah
we've
seen this one we know the story however
i hope the ending of this story is a
little different from the previous ones
because i think cigar just
you know really deserves to get a good
game off unfortunately
we've already mentioned this clock the
time is part of the game
so uh having good time usage is
obviously
going to impact yes
yeah in rook f7 it makes sense right
protect b7 rook f8 coming
and this is a move that he spent 45
seconds on
he can't afford to spend 45 seconds look
at his clock so
it just that's the tale of this match is
uh
spending copious amounts of times in
positions that he understands very well
and for eric and he's really just giving
a very few chances like he's pouncing
in opportune moments he's playing some
really exciting chess but
he's benefiting from cyber's
mismanagement on the clock
queen g4 okay so objectively speaking i
don't think this is a very good move for
white just because they will double up
the pawns
and you know and then that end game is
going to be looking pretty good for
black especially because it's going to
be bishop versus knight
however sucker is spending so much time
on this
oh my god he's being a bit of a
perfectionist queen six is a good move
okay that's an amazing move right it
saves the queens attacks c5 it gives a
discovery with d4 check at some point
but he spent 17 seconds and now he's
down to 12 and a half
he needs to play moves with that more
quickly but let's see he has a promising
position right now
eric is the one who's unsafe he could
take on f7 the rook will just replace
the first rook
and then now the f files blacks for the
taking so i like
cyber's position he just needs to keep
up the pace okay here we go rook f1
take maybe but i know my queen just
stayed protecting the g6 bomb
okay so d4 e4 okay i like that move king
h7 instead of committing to any choice
he puts his king to safety he protects
the pawn c5 is under attack
d4 i'll take it then i'll go queen a4 at
the end your pawn on d4 is weak
so queen b4 i like it bishop fa just go
for the pawn just do it
just go come on bishop of eight there we
go
3.9 seconds left take that pawn okay
queen
is gonna be three watch out for queen of
seven oh just make a move
i know good move though queen f7 queen
is gonna
oh no just go okay 2.3 seconds he needs
to move he's got
two bars yes yes yes oh oh we're going
on the offensive now
take on d3 remove that take it take it
okay two and a half seconds
pre-move it queen e3 check that's what
you have to learn how to do is pre-move
here queen e3
it won't be a bad move no matter what
happens g3 oh oh yeah he didn't have
enough time but queenie
uh queen three was good fujitsu is
winning oh he's gonna lose
g6 pawn no oh my gosh
oh no he got checked no
ah and the time is up both
in this game and in the three plus one
portion
how in the world that was such a good
game my soccer hurt it was such a good
game
he if he just had like two more seconds
two more seconds maybe you know i just
think he could have
oh my god and eric blanked him
in that section it was six nothing eric
rosen
in the three minute plus one second
increment time patrol
i mean i mean even though the result
is in the in the in the three plus one
time control is a
six zero that is not an accurate
representation
of sagar's chess skills because as we
all saw
he's playing absolute phenomenon
phenomenal chess
time is just something he's probably not
used to
um he's probably not used to playing
three plus one but he's playing
absolutely amazing
he really is and that's why i tend not
to focus too much on the
score like the result because they
didn't tell you how they played however
this is
an elimination match so he needs to
score we'll see if he can right the ship
it feels like it's getting too little
too late but we have
the bullet ahead stay tuned everybody
we'll be right back with this matchup
between
international master eric rosen and
international master segar shah
all right and we're back and we're going
to
be diving into the bullet portion really
really soon i mean
oh it's been a very very intense match
so far honestly like my heart rate is
just
sky high um watching watching them
battle it out with such high quality
games is honestly very exciting and
you know even though it's three plus one
you might think that the games are not
very high quality they indeed
are um and it's just being very
unfortunate for sagar
honestly that that time is just
ah some days it just it is just like
that right robert i'm sure we all have
those days
we certainly do i know them very well
not that today is that day but kind of
every day is that day for me but
uh you know it has been very good chess
you can see it from
uh from sagar he's playing well he's
just playing slowly
and for eric he's also playing very well
and he has the lead on the clock so
it's been sort of balanced on the board
throughout most of it
but that's what blitz is blitz isn't
just about oh let me find good moves
every move no no let me find good moves
and do it so quickly
so eric deserves the all the credit in
the world we do feel sorry for soccer
it doesn't feel nice to lose on time a
bunch of games like this but
eric has deserved every single game that
he's been winning he is pouncing and
he's
opportunistic and in that last game
there he was able to survive
in a way that most people couldn't even
dream of just to then lay the checkmate
and a win on the clock
and before we dive in the bullet portion
i mean i just want everybody to
you know show support for both players
eric and sagar who are both playing
absolutely stellar chess we've talked
plenty about how
sagar is very very prominent in the
chess community
however he is most likely not playing as
much blitz and bullet as eric
is you know so um he is however putting
up an
absolutely amazing fight and it's been
an absolute pleasure to see him play
very very solid chess today and the real
question is are we going to see
the stafford gambit i guess he can't
really play it because sagar isn't
playing e4
but when will we see those vintage eric
rosen gambit lines that's what i am
anticipating in the bullet
and for sagar we'll see if he just can
play freely the stress of the match can
sometimes
force your hand to shiver and you won't
play as
fast as possible but with sort of the
match result it's
you know looking like it's out of hand
maybe he can just move freely
yeah and uh this is not strict bullet
this is
one plus one which is still very very
fast wait why is he spending so much
time
i think his connection is struggling oh
no
yeah uh he's got one bar that i see but
he's still moving
and also his bullet rating is very high
his blitz rating was 22 something
his bullet rings near 2500 so
maybe he's better bull than we thought
maybe
i i love the way we put it i mean i
definitely think that maybe the
connection is causing a lot of issues
for him
at the start but but we're off now we're
we're we're doing okay now
uh he's making fast moves we're getting
to a very comfortable position for white
here
structure yeah the b4 a4 b5 palm push is
coming in
and these are the players we need to see
in bullet because it's so easy you know
these
five move plans that you can make and
there's not really much your opponent
can do
it's just easy moves to make while
keeping your time up eric however has
only spent four seconds and
sagar is actually down to 30 seconds so
yeah i think you know sorry here he
knows what to do but he's trying to be
perfect
taking on c6 at some point going rook
after c1 you just go after this pawn on
c6 but he made a big decision
there because after f takes watch out
for bishop f5 hitting the queen and the
rook on the diagonal
i definitely do like black's position a
little bit more now just because he has
the pair of bishops i think
that can be very very strong and can be
you know quite literally game changing
and get wait wait wait 99
yeah hitting the queen hitting the
bishop oh that problem was pinned
see that oh no remember to always look
for captures right guys
checks captures threats and that capture
is still possible but it's not as strong
because the end of it the bishop takes
f3 so
queen h4 coming in for a checkmate watch
out for h2 don't play h3 the bishop will
sacrifice itself
g3 look at those light squares though
it's
not so pleasant but no checkmate for now
so rook fc1 and it feels like black
should have an attack but if you don't
attack quickly
then white is just strategically and
structurally much better
yeah this is um rook takes f2 i think he
probably could have taken on f2 there
all the time and the time difference is
just
crazy yeah ten seconds for white but
he's
he's playing some good moves lately the
queen gets ready to start whatever best
free
only way take this bishop off but
there's going to be a sack on g3
yeah we already know i mean queen xg6
holds it for a little bit longer but
this is
okay well the bishop takes g3 very very
natural
mate checkmate oh no
yeah this is a a brutal finish but
that's actually how the game was going
because eric you know he kept playing
with purpose there
and sagar missed that knight takes d5
that one little tactic and after that
the game was clearly in black's favor
yeah we're definitely seeing some very
very aggressive
um gameplay from eric and this is the
kind of gameplay we we associ
associate him with usually so it's
definitely very nice also i just
realized this is the karo khan breyer
variation i didn't realize there's
another briar variation
uh i only know the one from the spanish
but chess.com is telling me that this is
another briar well i guess he was very
flexible as the chess player going
through
uh different variations and here it it
doesn't really look like a caracon at
all it looks like
uh you know some just solid positional
game it looks like a briar
yeah and now knight takes e4 just take
back if the
d takes we trade queens and bishop takes
now i can play f5 at some moment to
challenge your bishop on e4 but
all right cigar is not uh he's not
committing anything so sagar goes knight
to d7 and
he's moved knight to f6 he's playing
casually you know he's taking his
his leisurely base um
all right he takes knight all right
okay so what now what now bishop e6
looks reasonable the thing is i like i
wanted the long castle actually i was
really cheering for a long castle there
you know
so you can go for an attack yeah that's
that's why i cut away you know we go on
castle we play f4 we play f5
life is simple when you just push your
pawns up
it's true it's simple in either
direction either you just go and
checkmate or
you know you lose the game but either
way it's true it's okay yeah it's simple
right
like i'm with you and well speaking of
simple we've simplified
the queens are off the board this pawn
on a2 didn't was that not a free pawn am
i
um there could have been some c4 stuff
so oh true
yeah it's it's yeah you're right it's
getting sneaky over here but
white's pawn structure is compromised
with these double pawns but you also
have an open b
file that you can use to your advantage
so i would try to put a rook on b1 in
the near future
for sure i mean here you know you just
it's a very solid position i i think
this end game should be
objectively speaking of draw i don't see
a wave i don't like b5
because it undoubles the pawns
yep but it does give you a an eventual
attack on the c2 pawn right if you can
coordinate well enough rook c8 comes and
that could run but i like that move a4
really good move and we're just trading
everything off on the queen side so
your assessment of oh it should probably
be a draw that looks pretty accurate but
i'm looking at the clock situation
we're getting into time trouble and we
know how those games have gone
yep okay so we have just
a sort of clamp for both sides the c2
pawn is stuck in place the b5 pawn was
under attack
and brooke here i'm i'm wondering nemo
at some point there's like a rook b7 and
i take over the seventh rank and black's
king
can be in big trouble i honestly don't
really think so
um i think white's a little bit too tied
down now with
with defending his his own pawns i do
like black's position here
i think it's quite active but maybe now
rook b7
because oh nice look at that like
see eric is finding these moments where
that was hanging for one move it just
happened
but he noted the difference in the
position and he just takes that pawn and
now he's up
and you know i think eric did a lot of
puzzle rush recently
it seems to be time time
i i mean it's it's objective oh his
rating
was still um provisionary right
because i just saw a minus 42 for sagar
so he doesn't really play that much
yeah bullet but um i mean
black could potentially hold this end
game i don't think it's fully lost yet
it's just very very difficult for sure
right but time went out so now it is
lost and well eric keeps on winning his
bullet rating is above 2600
so he's thriving in this match it's
funny because he started off
on fire he was three and a half one and
a half ahead and then
sagar went two games in a row okay wait
a sec this is a match
and eric said no no it's not like i'm
gonna just take
all the next bunch of games so he's won
eight games in a row
for sagar the time control the time
trouble he's never been his friend
and also the internet troubles is also
not his friend
yeah and
i think that's why the clock is paused
for a moment we're just trying to
resolve the lag
uh for sagar because yeah it has been a
struggle with his connection
um so you know this match still has
nearly 18 minutes left is it possible
for
sarah to win the match still he'd have
to win eight games in a row
there's probably not enough time
mathematically speaking
uh if you know the games go in normal
distance so yeah it seems that
eric rosen will take this match and if
that happens
or when that happens i should say nemo
in the bracket
it means that he goes on to face levy
rosman so what do you think of that
matchup
of gotham chess versus international
master
rosen i think that this is a matchup
that all the fans have been waiting for
i think i mean obviously you know gotham
chess versus uh
uh eric
yeah this is gonna be really exciting
because not only
you know are they really big
personalities on twitch
and youtube they also have very
interesting game styles
right yeah no it's it's going to be a
matchup of fan bases that's what i'm
really interested in to see how loud the
fan bases cheer for their respective
parties there's definitely overlap you
know of course people can like more than
one person
but when it's a match of just two
players somebody has to win
and eric rosen versus levy rosman that
would be a fun one this is one that i'm
definitely going to be following
yes indeed so we think we're about to
resume
the play here hopefully the connection
issues have been resolved that the lag
is minimized and for sagar let's hope
that he can get a few good
bullet games in before the end of the
match just to feel like you end on a
good note it has not been going his way
since the five minute portion he
probably wishes that hey can we just
play that 5-1
over and over again let's keep with that
he definitely wants to buy one back yes
and this is exactly what happens when
you're not an online player so
while we have a moment i just want to
remind everybody of a great upcoming
event
it is the fee day online world corporate
chess championship and there's still
time to register so if you're part of a
company and you have a bunch of players
that want to take part
do get involved get register just do a
quick google search
find out the how to do so but it will be
february 19th to 21st
wait if i'm part of just.com am i
allowed to do it too
i don't think that chess companies are
taking part i think this is more
for other types of companies okay
yeah i think the chess companies would
win those kind of competitions but
i do know i do know that companies are
allowed to
have a ringer they're allowed to bring
on one player
and the maximum rating for that player
is uh one player over 2500 i should say
so you can bring on a player so nemo if
you find a company that needs a player
you can go ahead and slide you guys
already know what i'm gonna do
are you gonna start your own company
like yeah i'll just start my
you're gonna have employees you know
somehow i'm one of your employees
yeah yeah wait i'm thinking now i'm
thinking i i have things planned
the uh the bow test sister is part of it
nemo llc
yeah exactly i'm here for it so
yes if you're you do like chess if your
uh
your company wants to get involved you
can register i think the registrations
are still available for a few more days
but there will be some strong teams out
there because
in the new york city corporate chess
league there are teams like a couple
international masters on them i know
google of course well they're a huge
company they have
many strong players but it's going to be
a good event
this is going to be very exciting i'm
excited to watch this and it's going to
be like
there's going to be podcasts this oh my
god so much amazing chess content coming
up
for sure well while we resolve these
issues i think we're going
to take a quick break just to allow
the players to figure this out and when
we return we will have the finale of
this bullet portion
of this matchup between eric rosen and
cyber shot
all right and we are back the game has
already started and this is uh uh an
opening that sagar is pretty
familiar with right we've seen this
already twice happen at least
and yeah eric plays this d4 line so it's
a long time since we've seen this but we
like the position that
sagar was able to get although you like
initially black setup which i can buy
but in that game something went wrong
for eric along the way and then white
got that c5 like knight into the d6
square
so we'll see how eric hansel handles it
this time
i mean i definitely think oh wait this
is a tactic but does the tactic work
let's see okay so this is wilds if you
castle he'll take on
c6 and then take on e5 but black may be
down a pawn
but a ton of compensation thanks to this
light square bishop
here we go we have liftoff here wow this
is this has become very complex i mean
sagar came back from the break and just
suddenly started playing super
aggressive openings
i like this yeah he's down eight points
he needs to win the games and he's won
upon his knights coming to e4 what
attack does black have right you need to
attack
black has well i mean the the the a8 to
h1 diagonal might be a little weak but
yeah just get that bishop there but he
moved his bishop to f5 did eric and so
now the knight just gladly
stepped into e4 the queen can come to
well not to f3 anymore because the b2
pawn is hanging but at some point
that queen could consider going there or
hey why not let's trade queens i'm open
pawn
this looks great for white definitely
very solid position i mean this is one
of the first times i think in the match
when we've seen eric
actually lower on time so he's
definitely sweating a little bit and i
think c5 here
is extremely strong because then you get
your knight to d6 we've already seen the
knight to d6
um theme before but this one's gonna be
even stronger yeah i'm looking at f5 as
well to try to go after this bishop on
g6 but i dropped my c5
so queen c4 let's be wise about this
there it is
protect the pawn on c5 attack the pawn
on d4 maybe this rook can come to e7
pawn to f5
white's attack is really quick
yup definitely very very nice position
queen takes d4 also possible queen xb2
sure
okay i mean we don't really care too
much about the pawns at this point i
mean when you're going for checkmate
pawns are uh secondary you know i'm with
you there and rook be
that's a good move by eric eric has done
a really good job staying in this game
queen c3 offering the queen trade so
that the king feels safer on h8
and white does have plenty of time here
but look at that advantage
slipping i saw the eval bar just jump
down there
watch out for rook to b2 and check me
along the second rank
think rook to b2 yeah we're just gonna
queen e2 is forced here
or or i mean rookie two is also pretty
okay king g2
maybe yeah queen e2 though i like your
move just retreat
oh no wait no one would go
there's no way we're drawing this right
i mean this is the one chance you have
for winning and
there's no we can't draw this and eric
played for a win he went queen c2
instead of queen d2 so if he loses
it's unintended back to e2 e7 e2 then
you win this bishop oh
nope okay i said we're gonna hear your
trade wait wait
it's a free road take it okay finally
sagar gets this one
wait wait wait what wait what's like are
you doing some meat
oh my god oh okay it was it was just lag
it was just like okay oh my god i was so
stressed there for a moment
oh my gosh and eric put up great defense
in that game like that the fact that he
lost the pawn
but then drummed up all of his counter
play with his queen and his rook yeah
that was really well done but seller had
the time to calculate
that's why time is so important that was
a very very clean game
and by the way look at cyrus rating he
went from 23.80
whatever to gotta love that provisional
rating yeah
it has not stabilized because he hasn't
played enough games and he's
stabilized his position right now for
black is very solid here white though
doing well with the bishop on c4 a
little bit more active and
moves like h6 you think what has changed
the g6 f5 squares at some point knight
coming into the game
on this side but queen b1 queen a2 is
eric's first stop
okay so queen a2 go for the pawn in 95.
this is a very very easy easy um i was
just there for a moment
i was thinking about 95 and i realized
the queen protects f7 anyways
yeah and the knight at c5 is nice
because at some point you can just put a
piece on e6
and you can start trading off d5 getting
sharp is there going to be some kind of
sack here
whoa we have cyber shot ready to play
queen f4
bishop d6 let's go for that what
happened during that break i'm sorry
what did i
miss yeah what has he been fed like what
kind of
food has he been eating during the break
he's like had a couple of protein
bars and he's just ready for all ready
to go like
like he like we went we before the break
sagar was you know
using so much time playing like slow
chess and now it's just
wow like this is a beautiful chest like
it's just so aggressive every move is
with purpose
mm-hmm giving up all these pawns in the
queen side
the dark squares are more important to
me wait are we should we get the names
swapped or something
you know we're good here queen b6
bishop's e5 to follow
if king to h1 there might be knight h5
into the g3 square eventually you have
to watch out for rook 66
no i i saw it coming the rook won't
follow and the king is in trouble no
matter where the queen goes
this rook can either take this knight
with check or the rook and go elsewhere
to win the queen so as that's called the
casters
jinx or the commentators curse you know
um you know we won't praise the players
anymore the players are really just not
doing anything special it's just him
it's kind of blah
yeah they're they just they're just you
know playing normal chess
this is stuff you would see every single
day on chess.com yeah you know moves are
being made
the bishop is a bishop the knight is a
knight oh the queen
is a queen and that queen is going to be
a little bit gone yeah no rook takes d5
but sadly you get part two now you take
the knight that was in the way and now
the rook moves again
and the king is in check
oh gosh this is no
this is that was what a good game though
it was going great until it didn't go
that great
and credit to eric he was super alert
he had a bad position he knew that sagar
was had the upper hand and was playing
really well
and yet he stayed focused and he saw
rook takes e6 and he pounced as soon as
available i've used that word pounced
many times but that's because i feel
like that's what eric is doing here
he is getting some good positions where
he just puts sagger away
and then other times when it's
complicated and stressful
he's ready for the tactics when they
become available to him yeah eric is
playing absolutely
um phenomenon phenomenal chess for sure
wow english is very difficult i've been
like
trying to conjugate english words and
for some reason i'm struggling
i just say the base form of it and i'm
like wait that is not quite correct
you know nobody nobody can tell the
difference just don't bring any
attention to it you're good you're good
yeah it's fine it's fine
okay well we have a situation where
black is a pawn ahead but i would be
very nervous about this bishop on g2
hitting the pawn on c6 threatening a
takes b5 the rook is undefended
so some kind of like white's position is
so good it's like
sagar is getting into such good
positions and i'm just like
oh my god i'm so happy for him you know
yeah and he does have time right now 41
seconds to 31
at this point he's up 10 seconds knight
64 is a free pawn the rook protected b5
but the rook is not defended you want to
look
whenever their pieces in a row with each
other what happens when the piece in
between them moves out the way
unfortunately soccer plays e4 which is a
great move very tempting
takes c6 oh my gosh an e5 i see you
i see you with the tactics but this is
not what
sucker wanted because queen d6 can be
played trying to fix the pawn structure
and get a past pawn but if black doesn't
take then white
remains down a pawn yeah there's just so
many like you know exciting tactical
moves that can happen
in these positions um i mean here's c5
or rookie it's also reasonable but this
bishop on g2 anymore that's
yeah that's the sag bishop very do not
take on f5
do not take on f5 although f6 becomes
scary so you have to be on the lookout
for f6 in a quick attack
oh no you took on f5 that bishop is now
a bishop again it's regained its former
glory
yeah now it's a bishop again it was
going to be a tall pawn but now it's a
bishop
we have four watch out for e6 f6 the
rook on b8 is not defended so i like the
queen of four it's
trying to play for tricks 24 is also
good hitting c6 f6 still possibly eight
seconds
barely got that move off e6 is possible
f6 is possible
even what's going on here a lot of
things is happening i mean
eric is being super aggressive he has
three seconds twenty five quid four age
four
yeah that's mate and the queen's hanging
yeah oh he realizes that immediately and
just has to go i mean
sagar is going to check mate black into
moves oh my god
eric was playing really well i mean he
he had a bad position coming out of the
opening and he
he was like holding it but man
i love that i love it he smiles too he
knows what he's doing
yeah he's just he's having a good time
and eric is like he's a comedian at the
board
and he's one of those like he he just it
doesn't seem like he's joking and even
when he makes jokes
he just has this i don't even know how
to put he's just
i wish i had the word it's a very high
brow sense of humor
but eric is awesome and sagar he's a
natural
he is he is and sagar is you know he's
great you know he's
getting back some some wins here he's
gonna feel better about things watch out
for e4 okay the knights under attack
with e4
is a typical tactic to win the knight in
c3 but when analyzing like with
commentating bullet games all i'm
looking at is
can he take here can you take that you
know
it's just like it just becomes constant
tactics it's like doing mini puzzle rush
yes and there it is i see them to
deadpan here that's what i was looking
for
it is very difficult everybody to talk
chess try to come up with vocabulary
words
but thank you deadpan humor i really
like eric's sense of humor i've known
him for a long time he's
actually a great photographer for those
who may not know that and he
is often a journalist at many of the top
events so he'll play blitz with the
players in the free
time and he's just a great guy so i know
eric quite well
and and now well he's getting to know
sagar quite well and he plays f4
saying hey your turn to think you're in
time trouble i'm up 20 seconds and look
at this position g4 comes to mind the
knight on g6 isn't defending bishop d5
check knight to d5
use all the squares available to you
this is um looking pretty good
to see white for eric it's um definitely
one of those
i mean could've just taken on a five two
i'm sure but i i feel like at this point
eric doesn't want that pawn anymore he
just wants to
absolutely crush black knight c6
position yeah this is what i'm talking
about it's so hard to make a move in
this position it's like eric is playing
played this game absolutely beautifully
he came out of the opening with a tiny
bit of
edge yeah black played a little too
passively played a little too slow and
then all of a sudden this is what
happens
and the matchup it's you know out of
control at this point but if this were a
close match
this is the moment where you just resign
right you just try to get more games
going but for
uh sagar he's it doesn't matter in terms
of the match score
there's a little bit of prize you know
have some fun
he said are you not entertained and the
answer is yes sorry my apologies
uh but yeah the this knight in c6 was
the hero
it forked and then won the rook and now
it's back on c6
perfectly happy is that queen's like
almost trapped
but has the g5 square
and all right f5 forking more this is
the game of forks yeah this is uh
this was a bit of a painful game eric
played absolutely
beautifully yes eric's in
great shape right now and you know i i i
want to say that
it's one of these matches where the
story line often is oh
sucker lost on time and he had good
positions that's true he did have good
positions and he has lost some time
but eric deserves so much credit for
putting pressure
on the board and the clock even when
he's been in trouble
he has been the most resourceful player
that you can possibly imagine
finding these tactical uh moves that
save the day
just saying you know even if i'm lost
objectively we got to keep the game
going and
as if you keep the game going longer and
longer your chances to survive
increase and that's something we all
really need to learn from right it's um
not giving up when you're just worse and
instead just fighting back and playing
for that win
eric being able to convert all like so
many positions in when she was worse
into a win
that is a lot like that is
skill right there oh 100 and you hear
this from the top players all the time
uh because they get in bad positions too
whether it's magnus within tsukaru
but the ability to be resourceful and to
dig deep and never give up
that's an essential part of speeches in
particular
and chess more generally so look at eric
when is knight to t5 stole upon
c4 his queen is in line with a rook but
there's nothing you can do to exploit
that so you're
up upon b2 is hanging the bishop and the
queen lined up perfectly
it's going to be another win for air
maybe three oh
no another fork yeah now you can just
take them
be careful with those knights in bullet
chests
eric's knights you know he's just been
using them perfectly in this match
and well does what i even have a move
here i'm trying to come up with
something
so hard it's something that's what king
h1 was played
yeah as well as waiting moves
yeah bishop a6 take on e4 take over the
f file
this is uh pretty straightforward
yeah sagar is probably tired it doesn't
late
by him but he's not going to use it as
an excuse and the
thing he's going to say is eric played
great and my time management was bad
and for sure eric played great yes eric
just played absolutely
beautiful chess and look at this bishop
d3 take on a5 with the queen
all of your pieces in the game right now
for black and you are up material
so yeah this one uh
might be a go next angle
not much to say here other than you know
why it's just kind of
trying to hang on fortunately not a lot
of moves are even like possible to
complete
like you you know you can't barely move
your pieces you know everything just
okay well ricky one here is or
or or anything really yeah queen g3
first rookie one next
rook e1 actually still was possible
there because of the checkmate on the
dark square
there goes that rook and there goes
another victory for eric rosen
oh oh my god okay well eric is just
running away with this match i mean 14.5
to 5.5
yes that's uh oh he's thinking a little
bit
second move are we gonna get this again
we are we're gonna get this funky bishop
c4 but no queen e2 this time so it's
probably gonna go into the periods right
yes
and it's got like these vibes of a
potential king's gambit
that was declined but i like what sagar
is doing a5 going on the queen side
because you know white is going to
strike in the king side at some point
so get activity while you can on the
queen side
okay give the knight to 7 knight c5
i mean this position is just looking
pretty solid for white
yep but b3 bishop way to be together
that's like
you play the spanish often right and
sometimes that move you sacrifice a pawn
just to
shut down the bishop this is one of
those moments b3
i wouldn't think you have a rewrite or
bishop to b1 and then becomes a big pain
yep and he's going way too familiar with
this
i think we know that b3 is coming why
else put your rook on b8
yeah i wonder what rugby could be for
there it is but now this bishop is going
to come it's like d4 a3 and then the
pawn on b2
is defended which means a2 is followed
so it's upon sacrifice at this point
and black is not thrilled about that
even though he got the bishop off the
board
yep now we might see uh some
c5 i mean i think this is very good for
for wyatt like you have the center um
you have a really weak a5 pawn to go
attack
you have possibilities to expand on the
king's side like this is a dream
position
for white it certainly is and it goes to
show that
cyborg didn't want to sacrifice material
but sometimes that safer method
causes you more problems because look at
this he'd end up losing the material
anyway
so that temporary pawn sacrifice with b3
was justified and now
knight d5 is a threat to probably e6 to
stop it but when you play e6
the dark squares on your king side
become weaker so e5 knight
oh okay g4 trying to kick the knight
away to go knight d5
wow just going to go check my name all
right well
i wonder what rook h3 could be for i
don't know you tell me
maybe maybe we we want to you know just
march our pawns up the board
i love f5 here i see pawn i push pawn
and i like what oh that's a pin knight
and the knight can't be defended well
rick kicks h5 here
okay true the knight is hanging here but
at least you
quick counter shot into point take c3
and then c2 is hanging can i
take on c2 no rookie wait sweet take c2
well there was rook g6 that scared me
he's five seconds left all right true
yeah
30 seconds to five seconds so i mean
there's actually a lot of chances here
from
oh wait a minute wait whoa
why don't you just take off that was a
free pawn you want that pawn
i promise you you want it king king f8
run your king away and take on h5
saga is winning this week 1.8 seconds i
would play like queen takes e6 or
something to flag them
just try to win on time you know
but the thing is like you probably you
know usually in these kind of positions
i pre-moved every single capture
yeah preview vertically tried because
there's nothing white can do about it so
even if queen
queen should be terrible because rick
h5s comes with a chat eric is using all
this time now
yep but he's trying to figure out a way
to win on the clock and king there
queen each one good move queens for it
just go just go
all right if queen if one is working
three worker three oh i missed it right
three would have won the queen i've had
that lined up and now black is
even immaterial is that right i can't
count quickly enough
even material yes even material oh my
gosh and even on the clock
rook 8 coming to win the a5 pawn oh i
don't like this palm push
yeah because king of d4 check and you
can win the f4 7 though
rook f6 now is going to win for white
i like the king coming in though can you
eat three keys trying to check me he's
trying to check
king d4 go no it's too slow though
okay yeah it's unfortunate yeah rook f2
you're gonna lose g6 you can take out
four maybe there's some chances to draw
this but you're down two pawns
yeah i mean it's very difficult and that
pawn that passer
is uh rookie two wait rookie two and
then a four a three wait it's a draw
again
yeah somehow sagar escaped he's also
playing really
quickly like he he had one second and
now he has six seconds so he is warming
up
yeah he's in pre-movie he's getting his
bullet skills back and
it's eric who's the one in more time
trouble right now
all right so king b5 the time scramble
there was just crazy oh wait this is
winning again
oh never gets to f4 that's huge oh no
yeah and then you're gonna get the a
pawn and then two pawns and this is
winning
yep and you can even play with like c4
check because the king will have to go
away
now king two ah you just go don't take
an a4 oh actually you can because it's
not me rookie seven
pc4 back just go kc4 try to check my him
try to check him in oh
king c5 would have been cute there yeah
so it's going to be
a win for eric to cap things up unless
he lose on time
always possible but no soccer all the
time
oh what an intense match wow
well we need to go to break uh sorry to
cut you off there you know but we need
to go to break so we get the players in
we can interview them
hear their thoughts we'll be right back
with eric and sagar
sounds good
and we are back with the players after
was a very hard-fought match
congratulations eric you played really
well
uh so i'd like to start with you uh the
match was tied three and a half
three and a half after the five minute
portion what do you think went right for
you
after that um that's a good question i
mean i started winning games
uh consistently which definitely helped
um i think the shorter the time control
the more of an advantage i had i think i
i was able to avoid flagging in some of
these um
these crazy time scrambles and that can
uh that can definitely play a big role
so uh yeah i was happy with uh the later
stage of the match
for sure and sagar what about you what
on your end did you feel like
went wrong i would guess time management
would be part of it
but can you maybe explain to people what
it's like shifting roles from
somebody who talks about chess often to
playing it yourself
yeah i mean i was looking forward to
this match
uh very much i know that
all the chess knowledge that you gain by
you know writing
stuff analyzing games commentating does
not
guarantee you a good performance because
of the practical
playing skills are lacking so i tried to
cover them in the last 20 days or so i
tried to play a bit i tried to train
myself
i think if i had not trained myself i
would have done worse than this
so so i guess a little bit of more
training maybe
a month or so more could make this match
closer but
i think when um when the time was
running low uh eric was
playing very well and i think full
credit to him for
for winning this match yeah
no we just want to say to you sagar um
we both were
very very impressed with your level of
gameplay and
you know we talked extensively about
your involvement
you know in the greater chess community
and you know watching you play a lot of
the games and
having many many good positions
but then losing a little on time that
that that was very unfortunate
i thought uh eric made very good good
use of his knights uh
when he would close the positions and
then you know sort of
uh no lights are very tricky
he made sure nothing was hanging and you
know i i
when i tried to over push or something
then i would get trapped or
uh somehow hang something
so so that was uh one of the recurring
themes
in the match yeah i think knights are
more of a
like a better piece than a bishop in in
low time situations
sometimes even trickier than a rook so
have to value them more in blitz
for sure and well eric a question for
you because you are willing to mix and
match different openings
it seems so what was your preparation
like for this match and i mean you seem
to
really concentrate on some aggressive
lines at points and then other times
you're a bit more solid so
what was your sort of mindset going in
and how you would play
sure um i mean a big part of my
preparation i don't know if anyone or
everyone knows this but uh
sagar streamed a lot of his kind of
training sessions
with uh with adivan a strong grand
master so
i i tuned into a bunch of those and
tried to try it
he did homework
stream snipes well for one of them i
joined and then like the moment i joined
they
they were panicking saying like eric
rosen's in the chat
i was wondering like how they could tell
because i can't really tell on youtube
but someone was like impersonating me on
youtube exactly so
um but i was still watching i didn't
want to say anything though
but they were they were super
instructive like it's super interesting
to
watch like an international master get a
lesson from a grand master
and they weren't doing so much opening
preparation but i still got a sense for
uh for sagar style and
they were trying to scout out my
weaknesses so um
so yeah i was trying to uh to to make
games exciting
as exciting as possible to get kind of
my style
yeah i also checked your game with irene
yesterday and
you know so we we both tried to
get to know each other and also adipan i
would like to thank him he
helped me a lot in this match and it was
also my wife here she was following all
the games while they were happening
and so in the break i would go and ask
her if you know
is there something that i can improve
upon and then she would suggest me
so maybe that actually helped in one of
those
games where uh the catalan game where i
played
uh queen d3 i improved with quindy too
so
that's so i know yeah unfortunately i
don't have a wife to help me with that
well i actually have a question the
follow-up question here because you're
just
uh talking about uh working with adiban
um and you know you do a lot of
journalism i've known about your work
and followed you for a long time
but how much work do you put into
getting better yourself as a player
because there's a big difference of
course between commentating i know from
experience
i'm not improving as a player when i'm
commentating and doing all this stuff
but you need to focus on your own chess
so
how much are you doing and what is that
experience like
well i i was doing nothing much because
when
when there is work i i just don't
commentate i also have a
a company to run so it's like an entire
organization with lot of people working
together
so i specifically worked for this event
like two days i did not do any videos or
any
articles or something so the last two
days was very intensive i prepared all
the openings and everything
so i i think that it's it's different
like
with regular commentating and annotating
you can really get a good feel for chess
but uh if you then mix it up with
regular practice every day
then you can improve but i think the
priorities are set you know like you
have to
do some i have to make sure i do some
other things so i'm not able to
dedicate that time to polishing my
skills
but uh you know every time i play such a
tournament uh
it inspires me to start preparing again
so i want to thank chess.com uh for
for inviting me to such an event and uh
yeah last uh 20 to 30 days were great
fun you know preparing for this
for sure and i guess eric you know we
know it's getting late for both you well
for you in particular sagar and eric we
appreciate your time but question for
you you play against levy rosman
in the next match what do you expect
from that how do you see your chances
yeah i'm not sure um i'll have to maybe
start preparing
uh levy i've known for for a long time
we're good friends we're kind of rivals
a few weeks ago he called me out on
twitter wanting to
to face me in chess boxing and
i'm not really into contact sports and i
don't really
like hurting people physically so i'll
take your spot i'll fight levy
oh if you want to yeah you can play him
in chess i'll do the boxing part
so i'm gonna do yeah more uh more chest
preparation can take him down boxing
that would be
better let's go well you are
both two of the nicest people in chess
great ambassadors for the game we really
appreciate you
taking time with with us after a very
stressful and tough match so thank you
both
congrats to you eric and sagar again
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you back in more competitions
thank you thank you robert thank you and
uh
i also want to thank all the viewers who
are supporting also vidit was streaming
and there were a lot of people
watching it uh so sorry for losing so
many games on time but thank you for
supporting me
no thank you very much for taking your
time out
both of you to play thanks yeah
thank you so there you have it the
quarterfinals
are set eric rosen moves on to face
levee rosin we heard his thoughts and
nemo i just have to say they are so
wholesome that was
an amazingly friendly interview they
have so much mutual respect for one
another
eric saying hey i actually was watching
his
learning experience his coaching
sessions and i was learning through that
so it's really nice to hear
how even super strong players
international masters
they have a lot to learn they're working
on their game every single day when they
have a match coming up so
i really appreciate that insight yeah i
mean honestly i think the most
maybe heartwarming thing for me was how
much
effort really um both of the players put
into this match you know
um like just how much like
like cigars explained that he took days
off
uh from work and we we all have talked
about
how he he's mentioned himself he has the
company to run he has
a million other things to do but he
really was invested
in playing today and that is like
you know results are one thing but kind
of like hearing those kind of stories
like makes me feel really good you know
yeah and um
of course for eric as well i've played
eric and match before he's actually told
me he's prepared as well so it's just
always hearing about these chess players
and how
they're always looking to be the best
that they can be
that is wholesome and i love how
motivated sagar is like he wants to play
more chess now he lost
and he lost by quite a large margin but
he's like no let's keep going i want to
get back into this
and i love that about chess and it's a
good reminder that these players have
been
studying chess working on their game for
many many years
and it's hard to just go and play so
when you have an engine by your side you
know
even we as commentators we have the
evaluation bar it becomes easier it's
not stressful
and i know from experience that when you
jump right back into it it can be
difficult so
thanks to both of those players nemo
thanks to you for joining me for what
was a great match
for having me thank you and we want to
thank all of our viewers of course for
sticking with us tuning in and enjoying
the show there's more chess coming your
way title tuesday's about to begin so
i think we got to sign off get out of
here and the title players it's their
time to shine
all right see you guys
you